Four three, two, one,
two that didn't even get a picture
of you are going to get a picture.
Would you go with the Blow Torch or
the Samurai sword and found the flag?
What do you, um, I don't know. What does
everybody else do that mix it up. Some,
some folks go blow torch. It's that Elan
Musk blowtorch. I'm going to Eli Musk.
That's a good mood. Like that. You know,
why would I want to be like
Elon Musk and I'm saying this,
I don't want to be that smart. I
think that's bad for, you know,
when I was talking to him
and you know like one,
there was a moment where I said like,
what's it like being you? And he's like,
it's not easy.
Like he was,
he was like talking about
like the thoughts that are
bouncing around in his head.
I think his head is like a,
like a runaway train. Like,
cause his brain's just constantly
going. Well yeah, I mean but,
but to be that smart man,
you can come up with anything.
You could make anything to make things
work for you in life. Well that is true.
I guess. I guess. I Dunno man.
I want a little peace and quiet.
Kinda dumb be really ignorance is bliss.
You can just kick back and relax
sometimes. You know? I don't,
sometimes I just like to come home,
put the headphones on,
just lay back on the couch and listen to
music. Just just listen to some music.
I don't want to think about having
to fix the environment. Yeah,
I mean I see that too. I mean
I'm the same way. Don't get it.
I'm an introvert so like don't get me
twisted. Are you really never thought that
I could play the role though?
You know, I can play the role.
I mean that's all a part of like life.
Well I think you're both cause like
you're really good at being friendly and
like your fun guy. Like, like your
extra, you have extrovert qualities.
Well you need those to survive in life.
But is that what it is?
Like you prefer to be introverted? Yeah,
I prefer to be introverted. Like I like,
I love my alone quiet time
where I just sit back and chill.
But you seem to love being out and
being around people to too. Hang on.
I love that too. Yeah, you love that
too. It's like, no, it's kind of weird,
but it's good. That's a balance. That's a
healthy thing. Well, because you know, in,
in order to survive in life,
you have to be out there cause you
ain't gonna make money sitting at home
listening to music. That's true. You
got to get out there and showcase.
But you enjoy it though. Yeah. Well I
mean I, I want to enjoy everything I do,
but you're really good on Dana
White's looking for a fight. Oh, you.
Thanks for very good at that. Yeah. I
didn't know if anybody even watch that.
I've watched it. We have fun on it. Yeah.
It looks like it's a good time. Silly.
Nah. Yeah. Well, you know, me and Matt,
we have a good time. I love
Dana too, but like, you know,
me and Matt really have a good
time. Yeah, Matt's Hilarious.
And Him and Ray Longo who should
have their own reality show.
And everybody was saying
that from him for year.
Like Matt and Ray are like the
best duo ever there in the corner.
The absolute should be one camera
that's on them all the time. Right.
I know the fight pass. How's that? Right.
They have the option to go to the corners.
You can listen to the
corners do you don't,
don't fight pass has some
pretty cool audio options.
But with Ray Longo and Matt Serra,
that's a, that's a plus. I know, I know.
I love hanging out with them like they're
so fun. They're so long. All right.
Let me know. So long. I mean the
epitome of long. I'm one of them.
I'm going to go up there next week and
hang out with them actually. Yeah, that's,
yeah.
I'm a find it to find time cause I'm going
not for Brooklyn so I'm going to find
time. Oh that's right. That's right.
Yeah. Um, who do you have on their card?
Greg Hardy. Oh, interesting.
Yeah. Okay, cool.
I'm always nervous when I say that.
I know. Yeah. Cause everybody,
everybody's already cast judgment
for people. Don't know the story,
explained the story like key,
but he was an NFL player and
it was a very high profile,
high profile NFL player and something
happened. Domestic violence.
He had, um, allegedly, you know,
beaten up this girl and you know,
did some horrific, horrific
things to her. And um,
but somehow he never was convicted
of it in the case was thrown out.
What does he talk about it? No, no.
And that's the thing is that we don't
talk about it because I'm sure that's
something that he wants to
forget about in his life.
So I'm not going to be the
one to bring it up to him.
And I just know the experiences I've
had with him have all been positive.
Yeah, it's hard, right? Like you're not
a girl and you're not alone with them.
You don't know what happened. Yeah, that's
what I'm saying. Like I wasn't there so,
and I don't know how he is around,
you know, with his girls and,
but I just know how he is with us and how
he is with me. It's fucking hard. Right.
And it's also hard because you
don't know what really happened.
Maybe something happened, maybe nothing
happened. Maybe a lot happened, you know,
maybe it's exaggerated.
Maybe it wasn't exaggerated at all.
They'd be lost his fucking mind. Maybe
it's just you don't. The other thing is,
this is something that people don't
like to discuss, but fucking Tbi, man,
traumatic brain injury causes people
to do terrible things. There's desks,
just a fact that's just no,
don't even know why they're doing it and
they're there. They do wild, violent,
impulsive shit. I mean we see it with
fighters. We see it with football players.
I don't know what's worse for you,
but I feel like football's worse.
Oh Man. Them guys head to head
all day long. It's way worse.
Way Worse.
Even boxing is worst in MMA.
I think football's worse
too because of the,
the kind of impacts when dudes are
running each other to full speed super
athletes, you know, 250 pound man fucking
renting
some of those collisions.
You Watch me just your whole body aches.
Just looking at it like Ha.
And they have to do that. Like, that's
what the whole thing is predicated on.
Like MMA. Like for me,
I'm always saying, listen,
if you get hit twice you need
to grab. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's just a fist swinging right.
Not a whole body. Just like you said,
250 pounds. Just yeah. Even
like the hardest kick I guess.
If you get like neck kicked somebody
roundhouse kicks you in the neck.
I mean this probably
as bad but like, yeah,
or like wheel kicked. Like
when Edson Barboza wheel kicks
people. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When he did Terry Adam Rice.
Yeah. Yeah. We'll kicks you.
That's like full rotation of your body
weight ended at one kicked oh onto your
neck. Yeah. That's pretty bad dude.
His fight with Dan Hooker. Holy Shit.
Holy Shit.
It's hooker tough cause I got tried
to keep going but his body was just,
I would his Oregon's must've
just been a nylon lated yeah,
cause Barbosa don't play no train
with us now too. It he, yeah,
he trained the top team now. That's
right. He went to Florida, right.
He came Moodle flood.
Why did he decide to move to Florida?
Is Moitai coach was in Florida.
We, cause he was with Mark Henry,
Mark Henry. But it's Moitai
coaches, the guy who brought them,
who taught him everything from a kid.
And I know we reached out to his Muay
Thai coach to come down and work with our
team and you know, cause I think
he was in Brazil, whatever.
So he came with our team and then Edson
just followed him. Wow. Yeah. That bond.
Yeah. Well I'm telling you man,
he looks fucking good. I know.
I mean he's an amazing athlete.
He's so fast.
His switch kick is probably the
fastest I've ever seen. Yeah.
I don't think I've ever seen anybody
throw a switch kicked off fast. Yeah.
I remember watching a
switch kick and I was like,
it's like someone took a frame out
of it. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like a Bruce Lee movie. And not
only that, but he does like,
he's got a pretty high level of
intelligence in terms of fighting.
He makes that stuff work. Yeah. You
know, I mean, and I, I look at this like,
cause I've worked with, uh, with
mark the Khasi in case. Yeah.
Physically.
I mean just God given abilities,
but he just doesn't have the intelligence
to like make all that shit work.
He's screaming at the TV right
now. I know. I know. And I say that
and I, and I say that with all due
respect because he's my main guy.
Isn't he a young guy? Yeah. He's,
I mean early to mid twenties. Yeah.
Maybe he's just trying to figure it
out. Yeah. And that's what it is.
He's trying to figure it out and it
kind of pushed him a little fast.
So he didn't even have a,
you know,
a lot of time and have some Edsons
had some ups and downs, you know,
cowboy fight was a big down,
I mean,
he's had a fight that was a big down.
Oh yeah,
that was terrifying. Fight doesn't even
realize how goddamn good could be. Oh,
I know. That was like, that's the fight
that I put [inaudible] on the map.
Really for everybody to say, Matt, who's
going to beat this guy? He did to him.
Who's going to beat this guy.
Yeah.
But that's what I've always said is that
like if you had to pick like one thing
that you're good at,
like what's the most important thing?
It seems to me to be wrestling
because the wrestlers can just,
if you get a like a real high level
wrestler, they just dictate what happens.
They dictate where the fight takes place.
I don't think there is,
I mean you have to know how to strike.
You have to know the other things as well.
But I feel like if you have a
pyramid of shit that's important,
it feels like at the bottom is wrestling
and that motherfucker wrestles better
than anybody in that division. Yeah. I
mean, but see, I disagree kind of. Okay.
And here's why. Um, I don't necessarily,
because when we talk about wrestling,
I don't think it's necessarily
the techniques of restaurant.
I think it's just a waiter are brought
up dope, brought up different Stan.
Not only he,
they're definitely brought up differently,
but like any wrestlers just brought
up different, oh, toughness.
A different level of
toughness, a different level,
a level of competitiveness.
So like when you go to a Jujitsu school
was first thing you learn how to do his
bowel to Matt and kiss the
instructors ass. That's it.
You know you bout a mat and then you're
learning self defense and you learn to
respect and wrestling. It's not
about that, it's about dominating.
It's about winning,
dominating.
So there they have years of experience
of doing that. Like just that mindset.
It's also about being uncomfortable all
the time and it's like it or just the
room is always rough. It's always
tough. Like you go to a Jujitsu school,
it's a bunch of dudes smoking pot,
land back.
They roll five minutes, sit
back, smoked for 30 role.
Another five minutes you go to
a wrestling room is hot, sweaty,
they're all uncomfortable or all grinding.
So you take that guy and you
teach them some basic Jujitsu.
You got a champ. Yeah.
This is the mindset for me.
Physical strength to Aa, they got
physical strength. The grip strength.
I guess so important. Like for me like
grips is everything. And in wrestling,
you learned a lot of that early.
So I feel like that's kind of the
different searches brought up different.
Yeah, I definitely think
there's something to that.
And then also being able to cut weight
and still compete. Yeah, I mean,
so I'm always telling my fighters now,
like when you have that
restaurant experience,
especially if you wrestled in college,
like you go all your high school years,
you got 50 matches a year,
so you competing 200 times before you
even graduate high school and then you go
to college.
If he wrestled in college,
you compete against the best of the best
in the best room and then you fight MMA
is nothing.
It's nothing to you and now you,
and then you take a kid off the
street who's never competed before,
they're nervous,
they don't perform well there always
at a disadvantage and as somebody who
wrestled, right, because of the
experience in competition. Yeah. Yeah.
That makes sense. The only thing about
with some wrestlers, because of the,
there's like a tightness to wrestling
and some wrestlers just never learned how
to be loose with Ca. And some, some
pick it up quick. It's weird. What else?
The difference. And that's what makes
some of them better than the other ones.
When I look at, you know, obviously
Tyron Woodley, he's got it. He's loose.
He's got it. Yeah. Michael Chandler, when
he throw his right hand, it's loose. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, but you're right.
Some of them just can't get it.
And that's why they struggle.
And they struggle if they fight a wrestler
who can strike. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's terrifying for a wrestler who
can't strike to fight a wrestler who can
strike is terrifying. Oh
yeah, yeah. Absolutely.
Some dude who can keep it standing
and can fuck you up special.
They can kick too. I know. I know.
But I think that's another
problem with wrestlers.
They fall in love with striking
early. Yes. Jujitsu guys
too. Yeah. Yeah. And that's,
and that's, and, and that's
what messes them up, man.
He Fall in love with it and think,
oh, I have to be well rounded,
so I have to dedicate all my time
to doing this. I'm like, man,
but you getting worse.
It what you're good at.
Why I used to watch the George
group Shell fight. I'm like,
if you watch that guy fight,
you never know that he was a Brazilian
jujitsu black belt. Oh come man.
I used to get so mad at him.
I'm like, dude, what are you
doing? What are you doing?
Like he,
yeah,
I don't know if it was like
fan expectation or just
like in his mind he wanted
to be a striker, but I'd
be like, dude, what are you
doing? I think he liked it too.
And you think there's something to
that too? Something that they like?
I don't know. It gets weird when they
have that new tool. Yeah, I mean,
but it's ruined a lot of good fighters.
Careers.
I mean you look at Johnny Hendricks.
Yup. Or Josh Koscheck. They, Josh,
he fell in love with that right hand.
Hendrick's fell in love with that left
hand and then when it caught up to him,
Hendrick's is an interesting case
cause something switched off.
Something,
something changed with dark.
I like that guy used to knock everybody
dead and then it just stopped happening.
Like you watch his Martin Kampmann fight.
Mark Cameron went flying like
he had the death touch. Yeah.
John Fitch went flying like the death
touch. Yeah. Like he was some mash.
I mean he caught him early. Boom. Yeah,
they were flying. Yeah. Like if you,
if he touched you,
you are getting fucked up like something
happen and then all of a sudden
everybody surviving. Yeah.
I'm not sure. I'm honestly,
I'd have to look back and watch,
but um, I don't really know man.
He started throwing a lot of leg kicks
and just like taking a little bit of
steam off his shots, off his punches. I
don't really know. It could be injuries.
Like sometimes you see a guy, they as
they get older or they get injured,
they just, they don't throw
the punch the same way anymore.
It's almost like they can't throw it
straight. It's like they're kind of Yay.
Shoulders are fucked up. Their mechanics
are off. He handed it mechanics change.
You see that with our Lawsky
when our Alaska was young dude,
his right hand was up fucking piston.
Oh Man. He was great, wasn't he? Yeah.
Have you ever watched his
fight with Paul Blend Tello?
It's been a while since I've seen that.
But it's like the perfect
example of an ar Lawsky knockout.
He Kl Paul Bentel with a straight
right hand. It was just black.
It just came knocking off the shoulder
and it doesn't come off the shoulder
anymore. Now it's like it comes up almost.
Yeah. Like is he doesn't, he can't,
he doesn't throw it straight anymore.
It doesn't,
it doesn't seem the
same when he throws it.
Well I see him in the gym all the time.
He changed with us too.
So I see him in the gym all the time.
And,
and I mean obviously it's kind
of sad because you see them,
it's like you remember how great he
was and now like with age and injuries,
you know,
he's just trying to get through a
workout and that's not a knock on him.
It's just, it just happens when you get
older. He's 40 yeah. You're 40 years old.
So like your workouts are different.
Well it's also,
he's 40 years old with 15 plus
years of world class combat.
Yeah. I mean, if you look at some of
the knockouts that he suffered against,
like Sergei Keratan off against
Francis and gone. No, I mean he's,
he suffered some brutal fucking
knockouts. Oh, I know. I mean,
but just the fact that here's
our Lawsky this is, this is like,
I want to say he's like UFC
fucking 37 or some shit.
Boom. Look at that. Oh yeah. That was
straight down the pipe. Show that again,
real quick. This boom. I mean,
just the timing precision.
He was a fucking savage
back then. Yeah, that was,
you couldn't really do
it better than I am.
He was the scariest fucking
heavyweight on the planet for a while.
I made and he had a,
you know,
you gotta respect his career because he's
done a lot and he's still good. Yeah.
Yeah. And he's still good. He's still,
yeah. I mean, he loves to fight.
He still, he still fights
with enthusiastic. Yeah.
He just can't get his body to do
what it used to do in the gym.
Like it took him a while for
them to kind of lighten up a bit.
I remember he'd come in the gym, you
know, he's, you know, he's got that,
that Russian,
that scary Russian look to him and he'd
come in a jam and wouldn't say nothing
to nobody. But now he's
now he smiles. Smile.
It's hard to get these
guys to smile sometimes.
So as he down in Florida
now he's down to Florida.
When did he start going down there?
It's been like two fights, right? Yeah.
Maybe a little more than that.
He works a lot with Mike Brown and uh,
and they've been working together for
maybe long, maybe two years maybe.
So here's a Jackson's for quite a bit.
Yeah.
And then he just decided to just keep
moving. That's the life of a room.
Fucking rambling fighter.
Moving different towns and trying to
simulate, man, it's so hard. Single,
no kids yet. But they ended up doing it.
They get in girls and like they ended
up shacking up with a girl because it's
easier for him. And in
what way? Like when you,
you are struggling to fight or you
got nothing, hardly nowhere to live.
You find a girl and you shack up with
her and she'd pay all your bills.
Oh really? And that's what a lot
of fighters ended up going on.
That's why you see him end up like,
would they grow a young paying the bills?
That's never a good relationship.
Now girls paying the bills. No.
Especially when you're a fighter
and then you lose a fight.
She looking at you like this
mother fucking job, get a job,
get a job.
You got brain damage.
He's still eh,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a weird road when it's a weird road
when you don't think that you could win
a title.
Right.
Like every fighter wants to think that
they can one day be like a title holder
or be one of the elite of the
elite. Yeah. And then the hunt,
it starts out like that. It
starts out like that. Yeah.
It don't always end up like that
though. Yeah. But that's the weird,
the weird world is the world of the
journeyman. Like when a Touro God,
he used to fight Micky
Ward and we both knew,
everybody knew that these guys were
not going to win any titles. But yeah,
but you still wanted to
see them the fuck out of
each other. Still want to see
them go to war. Well, I mean,
but that's where we got to kind of draw
that line between like sport and event.
Right? Yeah. You know,
because like when we and fighters have
to also be real with themselves to is are
you doing this for the sport?
You chomp be a champ or are you just
trying to be a fan favorite and you should
train the way you want it on what
you want to project to the world.
And a lot of fighters don't do that well,
but if you're trying to be a fan favorite,
like if you're a guy who
just wants to bang it out,
like how many of those you got it in
you. It's not many, but some, you know,
Donald's Serone, you know,
he's, that's his robe now. Yeah.
In a way. But I think Donald's
still thinks he can win a title
as tough. Now. It's going to
be tough for him. Well, they
were trying to get him, um,
he was trying to get the Conor McGregor
fight. That had been a tough fight. Fam.
It would've been a tough fight for him.
But at 155 pounds is not a bad
fight for him. No, not really.
But I mean, the problem is
stylistically, he just does,
he doesn't move his head enough.
Yeah. You know, and Nate, I mean,
Nate doesn't either, but Nate took a lot
of shots, you know, to the hit. So I mean,
it's kind of a bad, I don't
know. Yeah. But Nate, Nate is a,
Nate is a very good boxer.
Yeah. Make a box. Nate Diaz is,
it frustrates the shit out of me
that he's not fighting. Why is that?
Because I like to see him.
I want to see him get in there.
I want to see him make
money while he can too.
I mean you're only going to be able
to live this lifestyle for, I mean,
I know he made a couple of million
dollars off of the Conor fight,
but he hasn't fought in two years
more than handling anything else.
Like put the dust employee a
fight that was going to happen,
but then [inaudible] got injured,
he's got some hip issue and then he
pulled out of that fight. I just,
I was looking forward to that
fight. I want to, I want to
see him back in it. Yeah.
But I mean I would have loved to seen
that fight and then never supposed to find
Mazda doll. That's, that's not
going to happen. Oh, why? I Dunno.
That's the perfect fight.
Great fight. The fight.
Where you going to got like the Hispanic
culture, the civil war and that's fine.
Yola going at it. Yeah. That
would have been a great stylistic,
they would have talked trash to each
other. It would have been crazy.
Whoever dropped the ball
on that needs to be fired.
I think nick just decided not fight. I
don't know. I do not know. I don't know.
I'm talking out of my ass.
I don't know the specifics,
but I was looking forward to it.
But then I saw an article that said Nate,
Nick Diaz confirms he's not going to
be fight in the UFC two 35 I'm like,
ah, what? What? Get in there.
Oh, come on man. Last time we fought
was Anderson Silva. That's crazy.
That is crazy. That's crazy. But I
don't know. I mean, I don't know Joe.
And this is something that we
kind of kind of stopped doing man.
Like maybe they ain't got it no more.
Well I don't know if it's,
he doesn't have it anymore because
we haven't seen him not have it.
He fought well against Anderson
and Anderson is 185 pounder.
I wouldn't lead down. Yay. Yeah, I mean,
I mean,
I mean honestly if anybody could still
fight in their older age to weigh those
two Diaz brothers fight their style
will allow them to fight longer cause
they're not like the best athletes.
City rely on skill and just endurance.
Endurance. Yeah. So they can fight longer.
So I'm assuming that they
still have something left in
the tank. I'm sure. I mean,
they're obviously not out of
shape. They're both things. Yeah,
they look like their fit.
I see them training,
I see pictures of them with Jujitsu
gies on and hitting the bag and shit.
This is, you know, who knows man.
I mean it's also like they want that
big pay day, you know? Especially now,
and they should get that big payday.
But goddamn, if I was the UFC,
if I am fuck yeah,
I think those guys are superstars.
I think the UFC doesn't know.
I think one of the reasons why Nate
Diaz versus Conor McGregor was so big is
because people love Nate Diaz too.
Yeah, yeah. Conor Mcgregor, no doubt.
Conor Mcgregor,
no disrespect to Eddie Alvarez,
but when Conor McGregor
fight Eddie Alvarez,
the vast majority of the
eyes were on Conor McGregor.
When Conor McGregor fights Nate Diaz,
you,
you're looking at a lot of
people who love Nate Diaz. Yeah.
But how do you think that happened?
Like,
how do you think Nate got
that says that star power.
You think he legitimately doesn't give
a fuck? He smokes weed all the time.
People love it. They love the fact
that those guys are like that. No Man,
but what does that say about our
fan base and our society? Well,
I don't know.
You know what does,
here's what's disappointing to
me that for whatever reason,
mighty mouse never became
a giant superstar. Yeah.
That confused the shit out of me.
I'd watch that guy fight,
you know when he took Ray Borg and suplex
him and caught him with an arm bar on
the way down and was like,
what the fuck does this guy have
to do to become a superstar?
I mean his skill levels
off the chart for sure.
It doesn't get hit for sure and put it
on it. He's a dazzling fighter. Puts,
puts on show skill for skill.
There's nobody on the planet who can do
what he does now. He's the best ever.
He's the best physically ever.
Yeah.
When the only thing that keeps him from
being thought of as universally the
greatest of all time is Jon Jones and
Jon Jones has been able to beat better
guys like John Jones, fight fights
a better caliber of competition.
Cause the 205 pound weight class
at least at one point in time,
had a deeper talent pool. Yeah,
but do you think of this? Ah,
yeah. I mean, I'm going to agree
with you there, but I will say this,
I think that sometimes we confuse
popularity. Actual talent.
Well,
I say yes and no because if you think
about like Daniel Cormier ne Daniel called
me twice day. Humble for sure.
Rumbles this rumble. Yes.
Knockout artist in the history
of that division. Okay.
Nobody Merck's people like rumble.
No Kid. Fuck that guy hits hard.
I know Jesus Christ. He's one of the
scariest, I would not want to mess it.
Piss him off.
I wouldn't want to piss him
off. Yeah. Fuck yeah. I see
him in Florida. I want some.
I'm always like, hey, yeah.
Hey, how you doing buddy? You good?
Can I get you anything? Stayed tight
as a scary motherfucker.
Rumble. Beat him twice.
Think about that and think of what he
did to Gustafson and what he does to
everybody. What he did. I mean, fuck man,
he did a little nog or whoa.
He just smashes people. Yeah,
yeah. I mean, you're right.
I mean, Jon Jones. Yeah,
you're right. John Doe the beat
a better caliber guys easily.
And he did it easily. I, I was
really looking forward to that fight.
John Jones versus rumble. Very. I
was looking forward to that fight.
I wish that fight took place,
but for whatever reason rumble couldn't
beat the best of the best. You know,
it's unfortunate, you know, I think,
I mean, he and he wrestled too,
so I don't know really know what is
performance anxiety was based on,
but he had it. But you know what, for
some reason he said after he retired,
you know, in the fight with when he lost
a DC, he goes, I'm just good at this.
He goes, I'm not really a fighter.
He's like, I'm an athlete. He goes,
I'm just real good at this. Yeah. Like,
how the fuck are you not a fighter?
You smash people.
I mean he's a terrifying fighter,
but he just does not his thing.
But that's the thing, Joe and I,
and I had to tell you,
cause when I'm coaching guys,
I have to identify that early and what
I'm working with. Are you a fighter?
You are an athlete, right? You're a
competitor or are you artists? Right.
I put them in four categories and they
have to be trained all differently.
If you had to train an artist, artists,
you got to let them get creative.
Like give me an example of
artists like uh, as a fighter,
I look at somebody like prime example,
we just saw them. Ryan Hall. Yes.
Ryan Hall is, and artists would, he
did that was like art. That's poetry.
What he did to Bj and fight the fight
world ain't really ready for that yet.
You don't think so? No. It's getting
there. But they're not ready for that yet.
Because when you saw him,
when he fought a gray Maynard,
he's trying to perform his
art gray. Maynard wouldn't
let him. So who do we blame?
We blame the artists. Everybody said all
bad Ryan Hall and kick them out of here.
He's a pussy.
He can't fight the smart way for sure.
He Maynard hits hard for sure.
So he fought him. He dove
for his legs. 15 minutes.
But when it works, we can
appreciate the art. Yeah,
we'll just gray Maynard was
prepared and he shrugged them off.
Here's an example of
an artist style bender.
Stop and artists or artists or
artists. Pure artists. Yeah.
Anderson Silva artists.
Artists. Like these guys are
artists and they can't treat,
you can't train them the same way you
train like a fighter or Natalie. Yeah.
You can't train on my deck.
Perry's a app and I know Mike Perry since
the first day he walked into a gym and
he's always had like does edge on
him and this chip on his shoulder.
I think he'd make it this far to be honest
with you. I thought he'd be in jail.
I swear to God. Wow. Yeah.
Wow. What made you think that?
Just says he had like,
he had a little chip on his shoulder.
He was always getting in trouble, getting
arrested, getting in trouble. But um,
I'm proud of him man. Like he really
turned it around and you know,
he's got a good head on his shoulders
while he's still in the hunt. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I mean, he can recover from
the cowboy fight. He's, you know,
he's got some holes in his game,
but he could shore those up.
But he's got the one thing that you need
in order to cover up holes and that's
power. Savage. Yeah. Power.
Yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Like even though he got
holes, he got power, not just
power. He takes it well, yeah.
Yeah. He's got a great chance. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. He's got a great chance.
Toughest Shit. Talk his mind like he's
an absolute fighter. You absolute,
so he's the type of guy you just, hey man,
get on a heavy bag for 30 minutes now.
Takes raw meat. Go fight. Yeah. That's how
you train him. You know what I'm saying?
You just let them go. Right.
But don't you like it?
It seems like what they've
done at Jackson's dough is
made him more calculated.
Made it more technical, like if you
see some of his more recent fights, uh,
before the cowboy fight, he's, he's
fighting a more calculated style.
I liked the way it looks better.
Yeah. I mean, so that works.
But the problem is sometimes it takes
time to develop and that's okay.
Like my parents still has time,
so that's okay.
But the thing is you don't want to
calculate his authentic too much.
Calculate his defense, make
him more aware. But then
when it comes to all offense,
man, just punch him mother fucker in
the face, punch him in the fucking face.
That's it. Right. So offensively you
keep them aware and calculate it.
It's like his attitude. You just want
to like keep it the same. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's a problem.
Is it like some coaches and I'm not
blaming nobody over there, but um,
but you just have to make sure
you communicate with them to look,
I don't want to change the way you think.
Right.
I just won't make you more aware and
you going to be a better fighter if you
don't just run out there swinging wildly.
You,
we need something to do
before you can swing wildly.
What was it like for you to transition
from being a fighter to being a coach?
Is it it, was it a seamless process or
were there some hiccups along the way? No,
it was, it wasn't a seamless, I mean
it was seamless as, as, as it could be.
It was no hiccups really.
Because I can, I can identify it,
I can relate to a rumble because
I wasn't a fighter. Really? Yeah.
I always thought I was
an artist. Hmm. So when,
when I was time for me to transition,
I said I no longer want to
express myself by punching people.
I'm going to show people how to do it.
Hmm.
Do you like taking people that are already
good and making them better or do you
like taking people that don't know shit?
I don't,
I think people that don't know shit
real. Yeah, I liked it. I like taking,
people don't know shit cause
like if you already good.
So I mean that's hard because like if
the already good and then you like,
you win a world title with them, right.
That's damn, you know what I'm saying?
Like there's no real, let me,
let me ask you, let me tell
you a guy like this. Okay.
What would you do with
Gustafson Gustafson? Yeah,
cause Gustafson that weird
spot, right? Can't be DC.
Can't be John flux up Glover to sharer.
Yeah.
It looks like a world beating
repeats. Jimmy Manoa. I mean he,
he's got world class talent for sure,
but it seems like it's just shy
of world championship caliber.
See but this, but as something that he
might have to like go soul searching for,
cause he might not have it, you
know, so if he don't have it.
So you just started going,
you know what,
I need to get vices and
make a bunch of money.
Do you think maybe it's where he trains?
Do you think maybe it's he, you know,
he's training overseas with,
you know,
he trains with the Leer Latifi
who was really good. Yeah.
I mean does he have World Class
coaching over there? I mean does he,
does he have worldclass sparring partners?
People that recognize patterns.
So that's, that's what I
think too. Is it in Europe?
And somebody mentioned this to me a couple
of a couple of months ago, is it in,
you're up to coaches are better really.
And I don't necessarily think that they're
better, but they're more attentive.
They're more attentive to
their fighters so they know.
So if Gus would leave his
coaching team as coaching staff,
I think he'd be at worst fight. I think
he needs to keep his coaching staff,
but maybe add something else to it.
We spent some time in alliance. Yeah.
And I think he needs, he needed that
he might need or just better partners.
He might just need a few better guys
to give him some different looks.
But I think the coaching staff
or his coach Steph is fine.
I've worked with someone before cause
Lro Latif he used to come to the top team
and I met all of them guys.
They're smart and they're more attentive
to their guys and American coaches,
American coaches, sometimes Guy Guy
Roller. Do what you gotta do it.
It's a bunch of good guys in a room. I
don't need to tell you nothing. Hmm. No.
So I think that's the biggest difference
between like America and then like in
Europe they're more attentive.
Do you think 10 of what is,
what's the reason for that? Just not
many. Not many guys to work with,
you know? So, um, you know, it was,
you go to the states here so big as
you go to a room, there's one coach,
20 fighters, right. Nicole is just
like, well you guys are good. Go ahead,
spar and whoever's left and going to
get you a fight. Yeah. And you're,
yeah. You know this, that's a
similarity with comedy managers.
It's a very similar thing.
Like there's some comedy managers that
have like a hundred clients and they just
like go out there and figure it out.
And if you take it to the top, yeah,
I've Seen Kevin Hart, oh yeah. Most had a
great manager. Look how good he got. No,
it's just fucking Kevin Hart. You can
have Megan no matter who was his manager.
And then there's some that have like a
small amount of clients and I spent a lot
of time with them. Yeah. And they,
they, they calculate a career together.
They map it out. You know, I think
with fighters a lot of times you just,
it is a lot of like who's who's
left, who's still standing. Yeah.
Who's still standing. And I think,
you know, being a coach, a top team,
we have a lot of coaches so I think
that helps us. That place is so big.
It's so big.
We have a lot of fighters but we also
have a lot of coaches so we can give a man
a Nunez a hundred percent. She gets
whatever she wants so she can get,
she gets the attention and um,
and I think it's just great because she
can get that attention like in different
places. She might not be able to get
it. I mean she would still get it,
but with the level of our coaching
expertise is just ridiculous to them.
That sure is a savage.
I know she's a savage when she,
she had a smile on her face when
she was fucking upside Borg.
I know she had like a half a grin when
she was digging and like is a half grit
teeth half smile when she was fucking her
up. See, Ooh, it's a, people are like,
they never, I don't think they gave her no
credit. I did. Yeah. I mean at all. Yeah.
She hits her, she knocked out
Rhonda. She'd knocked out,
you know what we should do?
She beat him.
He states you're Nakita goes out but
enable. Oh yeah, she fights like a dude.
But she felt like a brother. Yeah, she
gets the swag. You know what I'm saying?
She finally like a brother.
But you know what, to me,
I think one of the most impressive
performances was Raquel Pennington. Yeah.
Cause I don't think people give
Raquel Pennington enough credit.
I think Raquel Pennington
was one of those girls.
Like you see her first
fight with Holly Holm.
She almost beat Holly Holmes
lost by split decision.
Her fight with the Ashley Evan Smith.
Holy Shit was that chaos.
And she gets her in that bulldog choke
and chokes her unconscious like one
second left. Like it was mad.
That's blood everywhere. I mean,
that girl is tough a shit. She's
a super, you're right, man.
She's super tough and when Amanda
fucked her up, I was like, good Lord.
There was like, this is a
different Amanda. She's,
she's got everything now
before she had the power,
but she didn't have the endurance
and she would fade and you know,
like perfect example was the cats and
ganel fight. She fucked cats and gone.
Oh well pat in that first round so bad,
that cat's head was fucked
up for years afterwards.
She was having problems with
their cortisol levels are
hormones were all fucked
up. She gave her hypo
thyroid. She gave her who?
She killed her thyroid in
that fight. Oh my God. Yes.
Like she talked about it on my podcast.
She's like, that girl hit me so hard.
She fell. She gave me a thyroid
condition. Oh my God. Yeah.
She went to all sorts of serious
fucking traumatic brain injury therapy
afterwards. They did the shit they
do for soldiers down in San Diego.
They did it with her. She, she
went about it in detail with my,
on my podcast from Amanda. She's
like, that bitch hits hard.
So hard, like different than anybody
else. I mean she's just, I mean,
she's really good at hitting home runs.
Like she's swaying,
her swing to contact ratio on the
money on the button is just high.
Yeah. And the, the force behind it you
saw when she clipped sideboards? Yeah.
I said, what am I god, I know it was over
as soon as he, soon I saw it. I said,
this is over. This is all busy. Crazy. But
Amanda is another one. It prime example,
because I've worked in,
I've worked in all Amanda's camps
except for maybe like this last one. Um,
but she's not a fighter,
believe it or not. Really?
What?
What does she,
she an athlete or is she's an artist.
She's an athlete.
She's an athlete and a competitor.
So here's the thing, like, you know,
you can't just put Amanda and
go, all right, spark, she's not,
and you try to push Amanda,
she's not gonna, she's not
gonna respond well to that.
And that was why I think, you know,
in a fight she would out because like,
she didn't train properly.
She wasn't happy.
What really what her training cause it
was like everybody was trying to push her
like a fighter. But when you let her
do her thing, she pushes herself.
Oh yeah.
She pushed herself to the limit.
But when you try to take control
of her, no, you need to do this.
You knew that she's not gonna respond
water that, but you let her do her thing.
Coach, I got this. Go ahead. You do
it. Well class, best of weird. Yup.
So for her,
what was the missing ingredient when you
looked at it like the early Amanda too?
Like w s champ, champ. Amanda. I think
it wasn't necessarily missing agreement.
I don't think it was just everybody
was pushing her too hard. Really? Yeah.
Believe it until you're pushing her too
hard. All you need to come in, you know,
you come in and Russell for two hours,
you need to come in and do this.
You can't be a world champ if you don't
really train hard. And she was like,
oh no, I'm good. You know I'm good.
And I don't know if I'm down for that.
Just let me, let me do it. Let
me, let me figure this out.
Let me figure what my body needs and what
she figured out, what her body needs.
She said,
hi,
I'm a push myself and she gives no less
effort than what she would have gotten
before.
But she made a decision so maybe she
just doesn't like people telling her what
to do. I think I, yeah, I think
that has a big part of it. Yeah.
Cause like she's now the best of all
time. Yeah, no doubt. How does she,
she knocked out Cyborg in 50 fucking
seconds. She beat everybody. Yeah.
She fucked up. Me should take, I
mean she fucked up Ronda Rousey.
I mean she fucks up everybody. I know
she's the best. She is. No doubt about it.
No doubt about it. Beat
Valentina twice. Yeah. Yeah.
Anybody is other than her, who
is the best? It's Valentino.
Valentino is a beast.
She's a beast.
But I think that the more
confident Amanda gets,
she just walks Valentino down a beach.
She walks her down and beats her up.
If they fall, he's too big. Yeah. She's
just too big. Too good. Too quick.
So God damn long. But Valentina
so skillful. She's, yeah,
and that's like stylistically it
doesn't make for a great fight because
Valentina is so skillful, so like
it can show some Adderall. Yeah,
she gets the raw water and she's got
good defense and she moves her feet wet.
Yeah, she's really good. Yeah. I feel
bad for them. Other girls flyweight yeah.
Well she might take over that division
for a long fucking time. Yeah, for sure.
I mean,
if you look at what she did,
she shut you on Jay check down and Yung
j check was way healthier, way healthier.
Flyweight then she wasn't straw way and
I feel like Straw weight, she just sucks.
Too much weight. You know, drains
or too much just she doesn't,
she's not as durable because you look
at the shots that she got hit with by
Valentina, they're probably
arguably harder shots. Yeah,
but she just, you're right.
She's more durable. Just not,
she can't cut that weight and
perform at the same level. Yeah.
I don't know why fighters feel
like best to answer all the time.
Cutting away at and weight cut
and wake. I hate it. I hate,
I'm like if you're going to allow seven
pounds to dictate whether you can beat
this guy or not, you got a problem. Yeah,
that you're not that good then. Yeah.
You should never allow like seven
pounds to dictate whether you could beat
somebody or not.
Do you think that the sport would be
better if they eliminated weight cutting
the way one fc did? I think so. I think
so too. I think I wish they would.
I think the performance would be better.
I think guys would be more durable.
They'd be able to take shots better
and I think there'd be less bullshit.
I think they just need more
options in terms of weight classes.
I think that's one. I think because
there's just too many giant jumps,
like a five to two oh five like what
the fuck is that? 20 pounds on lot.
Well, I mean that's just one issue with
the sport is like incredibly antiquated.
The weight class, I mean this stuff
was 20 years ago. I mean it was,
and we keep it at the same, like the
pay structure antiquated when bonuses,
but not when I'm like,
why are we have a window guy for winning?
You paying them double to
win. Yeah. Well not only that,
you're paying these assholes to judge.
Yeah.
Judging is terrible.
You paying people who don't know what
the fuck they're watching. There is.
I would love, I mean there's some
great judges, don't get me wrong.
If you're listening and you're a
judge and you're great, thank you.
There's some terrible judges and I want,
I would like to know how many
of them have ever even trained.
Probably not many. If you,
if you're watching someone,
there's some crazy scramble and some guy
almost catches someone with something
and the guy gets away and almost catches
someone and it gets way the person who
doesn't train. Do they even understand
how close it was? Like how do they, yeah,
they don't, they don't know. How
could they know? How could they know?
They can't add. They can't. But, and,
and sometimes I get in arguments
with people about this too.
Another thing is like this,
you know, to open scoring.
I feel like we need open scorn.
I love that idea. I'm like,
cause as a coach you go into a fight
and like there's certain things that you
want to do and certain rounds based
on where you are in the fight. The
only argument against it is
that a guy would coast. Yeah.
Then the other guy would go crazy.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Yeah.
I think it would be more exciting and go,
oh he's going to coach,
but this was happening.
Now it's both fighters are coasting
because they thought they won. Right.
That's both fighters are coasting
because they thought they won you.
You have to be crazy to think
that these judges got it right.
You have to be crazy. Yeah. I feel
like you won the first two rounds.
Like I got this. Yeah. You gotta be crazy.
Yeah. Hey, you never know. You never know.
Guessing. Yeah. I think sometimes they do.
I think they do too, but I'm like, man,
if I knew what the score was
going into the third round,
I would be have be able to tell
you better what you need to do.
Do you know Doug Looks Crosby?
You know he's a referee or judge whether
he told me once they're in the middle
of a fight and some
woman looked over at him,
a guy had another guy in the Komora and
he's like, what is he doing? What is that?
Oh my God. Like what
is a Kamora? Oh my God,
this is not something crazy.
And I mean he said a guys that are
in charge of your life, your career.
Career. Yeah. And especially
in MMA. I mean, look,
it's terrible in boxing as well
as terrible decisions in boxing,
but this one is insane because it's
50% of your purse when bonus is 50%
in most cases. Yeah. I don't even
know why we still do that. Hate it.
Why do they still do that?
I hated guys fight their heart out.
They should get what they're
supposed to get paid. Yeah,
you should get what you get paid and the
only bonuses should be for finishing.
The idea that someone's
not going to fight hard,
like the knock going to fight
as hard as they would if they,
the guys want to win. Yeah.
Everybody wants a win for sure.
Fight any harder, right, because
there's a wind bonus. No, that never,
I've never come back to a guy in
the corner and be like, hey listen,
you got that win bonus.
You got to win,
but you got to witness because of the
wind, but no, you want to win anyway.
Some advice to fighters to stop
asking for those performance bonuses.
You're not going to get them when you ask.
It just doesn't work
that is that what it is?
They never get it unless they
need. It's obvious. Yeah.
You know there's some like
some wind bonuses where
you're like, of course. Yeah.
Well Connor started that whole thing,
didn't he? Did it? I think he did 50 g's,
baby. I think he might've been the one
to start that. Maybe he did, but again,
it was probably a performance
where he was going to get it.
[inaudible] he would have probably got
to, anyway, he had a probably got it.
Anyway. There was some guys do it on
fight pass prelims and I'm interviewing,
I'm like, man, I to get with shoes didn't
say that. You're not going to get this.
You might have gotten it if you didn't say
nothing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's this, uh,
I don't like that either.
I don't, I, I feel like the
performance bonuses, I'm like,
ah, I think they should give everybody a
bonus if you finish because then you're
going to get guys looking to finish.
That's a great idea. That's a great idea.
Having a finished bonus. Yeah.
Oh, on every fight, every fight.
If you finish here,
you get paid what?
You get paid when a loss and then there's
a few finished amount of dollars for
every finish, finish, 20 grand, whatever
it is. You finish it. I agree with that.
That's great. I think that, uh,
I, I do think that there's a real,
I think it's unfair that
you don't fix the judging,
but yet you also have wind bonuses.
I think that's unfair. It is. Ah,
I don't like it.
The fact that you just told me that story,
I got breaks my heart to think that
these guys are judging and control of
everybody's career and he don't know
where to come more is there's a lot of
people like that out there. There's
a lot of people. I thought it,
I mean we've seen,
we've seen scores where it's just so like,
this is what I think. I think first
of all three people is too few. Yeah.
I think seven should be the number.
That's a good number.
I would think I would like this.
I would like, like a good number,
like seven maybe. But then on top
of that, I want an online score.
I want to see what people, and
I want to get like, you know,
just experts like get a bunch of
fighters to give their input on it.
Like have a pool of experts. Yeah. You
know, it's like what it Tyron Woodley.
Think about that fight.
Oh Tyron is watching it at home.
He felt like it was this what, what did,
what did mighty mouse Johnson thing.
What did, what did Jon Jones thank
like if whoever wants to contribute,
who wants to contribute to the pool,
like have a verified account and say
this was, I'm scoring it at home.
It was this, you know, this, it was that,
and then you look at this online pool,
like 90% felt it should have gone this
way, but the judges went the other way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Shit. Yeah. That kind
of shit would be very telling. Yeah.
And I don't get it like, cause we
all look at fights and go, all right,
that shit was not, that's not
how it went. This guy won.
But we all know he didn't win that
fight. What's like the bay? Can you put,
I'm trying to think of like what's the
most egregious example that you could,
you could come up with? Well I just saw
a fight in a, where was I? It was a,
Justin Scoggins fought a kid this recently
and I think he had dropped from USC
from that loss and it was a bad decision.
Oh the terrible. I'm thinking, Oh yeah,
I went, in fact I left to get something
to drink cause I was like I am.
He wanted that got dropped. Yeah. He just
fought in like Japan or somewhere. Yeah,
he's good. Yeah. He got
weird style tip sideways.
Looks like a small like Wonderboy boy
to go wrestle. Yeah. Yeah. Interesting.
What else? From the same area? Like I
do a lot of karate up in the Carolinas.
I think it's interesting.
Yeah.
Did you see that Robin black
breakdown of the dude this,
I've always said that one thing that I
used to see in sport karate and I see in
taekwondo was sliding. Like guys knew how
to lift up that front leg and slide in.
Yeah, it doesn't, I don't see that a lot
in MMA, but if someone was good at it,
there was like,
there was a guy that I used to train with.
His name was Larry Jones and Larry was
a, he was tall. He was like six too,
but his legs went up to his
armpits, man. It was crazy.
Which is fuck people up with his
front leg and taekwondo tournament.
He would just slide across blam yes.
Slide across.
And people just didn't know
what to do with that front leg.
They were trying to figure out
that front leg and Robin Black, uh,
see if you can find this. I think
it's on his Instagram. This dude,
I don't know who the guy is.
I never seen him fight before,
but he slides in with a sidekick.
Plam slides in again.
Blam and then goes to the
guy's face with this. I mean,
he's covering like 15 feet with his one
leg up in the air and one leg down just
sliding in with his hips and his momentum.
We'll see.
That's a unique skill to have. And I gotta
tell you, and like when me and Tyron,
when we first started training
for the one boat Wonderboy fight,
we couldn't find anybody
that could do that really.
And that's why a lot of people have
problems with Wonderboy because, oh yeah,
just get a bunch of guys. I could strike
posts of his striking is different.
It's different. It's different for
it. And here's the guy. Look at this.
Watch this guy do. Is it this
one? Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Do it
from the beginning though.
Yeah, but just reset it. Watch this
guy. Watch how this guy does this.
This is crazy. This is your one minute
CIA slides. Yeah. Look at this slide.
Watch this. Boom. That's some
serious slide. My goodness.
Serious coverage.
The distance of that incident that you
see a lot in those sport karate guys,
especially guys that know how to
correctly throw a front leg side kick.
And this dude, whoever this gentleman
is, he really knows how to do it.
What is his name? Jamie
folding. Jamie phone.
Click on his shit. I got to follow
that dude. Oh, he's a guy too.
Dang. He's gonna be tough. So I'm serious.
Fucking power would that front leg.
But it's, he's also, if you watch,
go back to that original clip again.
You watch what he does when he does it.
Watch how he lifts his knee up.
Waist Height,
which is critical because everybody,
the, the people that do it wrong,
their knee is low,
their knee is low and they're kicking up.
He's his Nigos high.
His nigos like when he throws it,
it comes off straight. See,
look how high his knees,
his knee is like upwards hip is,
and then as he throws it,
he throws it in a straight line
and you just get all this power.
See he even delay like he
just hop, hop, hop range.
Danny delivered.
Yeah man.
I used to see a lot of people in the the
taekwondo days that we're real good at
this and very few in MMA
until this guy like bang,
like that is a fucking look
at that stretch on this dude.
That's some serious flexibility to and
to fuck a guy up at the front leg side
kick to the dome like that.
That's incredible.
But it's the slide that's the most
impressive. The distance he goes. Yeah,
you're not used to that. You think
you're okay cause you're outside,
but you're not even nearly outside.
You're,
you're right in the wheelhouse and like
he doesn't have to change his position
and he's not, he's not vulnerable to
a lot of attacks weighing like that.
Wonderboy has an interesting way of doing,
it's a little bit different.
Wonderboy does a slide but he,
his leg comes up from the ground,
like he's lifting his foot up and
you're not even sure what it is.
And then as he's extending it, it's
still low and then he brings it up. Yay.
Stabs you in the stomach with
it. And you're like, what?
The Johnny Hendricks fights
a great example of that.
Johnny didn't know what the fuck he was
doing and then Johnny smiled and then he
got roundhouse kicked in the face.
Like what? Well, I'll tell you,
I mean it's just because like the way
Johnny came up a little bit later,
he came up after I did, but when I was
coming up, nobody, you couldn't do karate?
No. So karate, no karate. You do karate.
So like that,
that whole stigma towards karate,
just like it carried on for so long that
now like if you do karate, you got up,
you got an advantage because nobody
knows how to defend it. Right? Yeah.
There's definitely something to some
stuff. As long as you do the other shit.
Yeah. Something to some styles of karate.
Yeah. Connor does a lot of karate. Yeah.
You could tell me you see it in his style.
When we fought Aldo,
he'd tried to front leg,
so I kicked to the thigh back,
but he's got a karate style. He's
moving in and out. Karate watches.
Not Moyie Thai. No. He's very elusive and
then, but when he gets him boxing range,
he'd put them hands on. Yeah, the boxer.
Yeah. That's an interesting style.
That's an interesting way of doing it.
There's a,
there's just a bunch of different ways.
That's the beautiful thing about MMA.
There's a bunch of different ways to
do it, man. There's Ben aspirins way.
Just grab a hold you in. Gorilla fuck.
Begged me to the ground is my man.
That dude, I've known Ben since before
he started fighting. Like he, he came,
stayed at my house, my dog bit
him and shit. Your dog to him,
you had a little Chihuahua.
Beethoven Shit. Ben. Yeah.
Ben Is my homeboy man. And,
and I think that,
uh,
I was nervous about him going into UFC
because I was thinking it, you know,
they was gonna get him too late. Yeah.
You know, because like when he, you know,
but I still, I think he's still
easily, he's never taken any day.
He never takes no damage. So I was just
nervous that they get them too late.
But you know, Ben has been instrumental
entire Woodley's camps. I mean, he's just,
his brain is just like, we
think on the same lines, but
he's, he's a brilliant guy.
He's always sending me books. Justin's
like, he's smarter shit. Yeah.
But he's also very analytical in his
approach, you know, like he's not,
he's not gonna, you know, no disrespect
to George Groh Gel, but George go gel,
abandoned his Jujitsu and to start
banging. Ben's not, no, no. He,
he's never going to do
that. Yeah. Never happened.
And I liked the way he thinks too.
He's like, you know, like he didn't,
he doesn't spend time away from what
he's good at. He stays in that row.
Always coaching. Constantly
wrestling. Yeah. Yeah.
He's always coaching kids. But I mean
even even with himself like we'll go,
we'll go up there bending China for
nothing will go up and Ben will give Tyron
how ever many rounds he needs. Real. Yeah.
You know most guys I've got to bring it
like two or three guys and they get time
or some work battle,
give them work no matter what.
No matter what kind of shape he's in,
he give tower and work.
Well he was talking about, you know if
they do open up that 165 pound division,
which I guess they're talking about
because there's so much talent in that
division.
I really think if they moved it to 75
and they had a 65 75 85 I think that's
better. Yeah. And then Ben would fight
at 65 cause he doesn't want to, you know,
fight Tyron,
tell him and tire and a real good friends.
But I like a lot of match ups with him.
I really love the Robbie Lawler fight.
I mean, I know they pulled off that fight
because of the Anaheim card fell apart,
but they're going to fight.
Um, is it on Brooklyn?
I think they're fighting March 2nd. Is
that what it is? I think Sissy Robinson,
him and Robbie and I felt like they were
going to make that a headliner for a
fight night.
I felt like I saw a
Robbie's face as a head.
I don't know if that's been
solidified text and ask. Yeah, right.
Or Text Dana. Um, it's a,
it's a great matchup though.
That's where you see where Ben fits in is
against worldclass competition. I mean,
you'll see where he fits in against world
class competition or see if Robbie is
done or not. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
It's a great fight for both guys.
Or if Robbie is still a savage.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I mean,
I like Robbie taking the time off too.
Yeah. I think that's important for Robbie.
I mean, you look at the wars. Yeah.
I went through the Carlos Condit fight
before the fucking Rory Macdonald fight
to me. Good. Jesus Christ. I don't know
who gets out of that unscathed. Oh,
not a single human that's ever lived
gets out of that. And he needed that.
He needs time off. Yeah. Yeah. Cause
we didn't get hit like that and just,
he's a savvy, he's a fighter. When he
was screaming and his lip was split open,
I mean it was like a zipper was open.
Yeah.
And scream and I'm interviewing him
after the fight and I'm like, dude,
I could see your teeth.
Like literally see his teeth right
through his, his mouth right through
his lips. Oh yeah. My God. Yeah.
And he didn't give a fuck. No.
Stitch it up. No. Like, yeah, he's,
he's a fighter man. Like that's, that's,
that's the type of guy like, Hey,
get on that bag. Yeah. And those meat
at you. Well he used to not even spar,
which is really crazy when he's fighting
in Strikeforce. He wasn't even sparring.
And I asked him about, he goes, man,
I already know how to fight. Okay,
questions are over. Thank you.
Well, I mean also till you got an a,
but you got to look at it too, like
where he can, where it comes from.
Like you know them dudes in the
Midwest don't got no filter.
You know what I'm saying?
They was just trying to kick the shit out
of each other. Every spar and practice.
That was every practice, every
practice days, just knocking guys out,
drag him off the floor until they wake
up and then bring another guy and then
when you wake up,
bring them back in the back end.
It's really crazy when guys get KOD.
I remember that from boxing gyms.
You'd watch guys get dropped and then
they'd be sparring like 10 minutes later
like what are you doing?
You should be in the hospital.
Do you understand what just
happened to your brainstem? See,
I don't like that part of the game.
You know what?
I don't even know if it's even necessary.
It's not necessarily necessary.
It was ignorance because if that guy
gets hit again, he could get like,
do you know Joseph Valtellina after
he beat marked a bond and glory,
he won.
He won the title.
He was fucked up for months like he could,
he couldn't have any lights on.
He got to be in a room.
He said that the light from like a
charger from a cell phone charger,
that little tiny little light would fuck
his head up. He'd give him headaches.
He had a severe concussion
of a, from a fight. He Won.
He got clipped with a giant knee
in that fight and just boom,
send his head back.
And even though he won the fight,
he still was fucked up for a long
time afterwards. I was looking at,
you sort of see two 35 takes shape,
but to title fights in three x UFC champs.
So is that on the cards? It
says it's Jones. Anthony Smith.
Who Tyron versus Kamar who smile
and then ask her an and Lawler.
Whoo. That's it. There we go.
Is that March 2nd you, uh,
that's in Vegas, right? Yeah.
God Damn. Pray to the MMA.
God's Keith that card together.
Keep that a and then don't forget a
Pedro Munoz and I'm Cody Garbrandt. Ooh.
Wow. Wow. That's a fucking card. I know.
Fucking card.
Julio homes also on it.
It's about Holly Holm. Aspin
lad. Don't get rid of that Ad.
Does that beat and Jeremy Stevens.
Holy Shit.
Gotta love it. Gotta love it.
Mickey Gallen Diego Sanchez.
Jesus OVN St Pru.
Aronov man,
that's a great car. That's a fucking
crazy card. That card bombs away, man.
That is a bomb's away card.
I um,
I don't know about the Anthony
Smith and John Jones. Wow.
I wonder why they, I don't even know why
they made that fight in the first place.
They probably just wants to needed
John wants to fight again. Really?
Yeah. John's probably won't look,
he had to take two years off.
No money.
All that bullshit finally gets
his title back. Cause like,
let's keep this ball
rolling. Yeah. You know,
and then probably also feels like the
best way to get back to like his top form
is to compete regularly,
you know,
gets loose so he could really
show what he can do. Yeah. I mean,
although the fucking pressure that
must have been on John from that fight,
you know, I mean, pardon me, that
wants to feel bad for him. I mean,
there's a lot of pressure on this young
man, but then a part of me is like, man,
will you stop fucking up?
Yeah. It's, it's, again,
I think it's what we're talking
about with fighters and you know,
they're crazy impulsive.
The why make mistakes so you stupid shit.
Especially if they like to party. Yeah.
You add that into the mix. I'm like, Ooh,
you're gonna make some piss.
Poor decisions.
And I should've saw the
science how hung out with John.
This was before he was big time.
It was in buffalo is like
some small show in Buffalo.
Like I don't even know why he was there.
And like,
he was just doing like fucking Jack
Daniel's like out the bottle. I was like,
what the fuck?
But that's also why he's so good.
He's such a wild motherfucker. That's
Po. I mean there's, there's, uh, an, uh,
an ingredient list and great champions,
you know,
and part of it is they just don't give
a fuck. They just are good. They go.
And that was what I was
saying about Amanda,
when you allow her to not give a
fuck and don't try to control her,
she's going to fucking
rise to the occasion. And,
but the problem is it doesn't work for
everybody because some people need to be
controlled because they can't rise
to the occasion like that. Right.
When you let them do their thing,
man, he just rise to the occasion.
It's fun trying to figure out what
is that, what's the right mix? Yeah,
it's a Mike, Right. Mix of discipline and
conditioning. But then just being free.
You know, Dominick Cruz brought
this up. We're doing commentary.
It's like some guys fight better with
like a week's notice. Yeah. They just,
no pressure. Just, she'll just
show up and they're good. You know,
some people fight better
than the underdog. Nobody's,
nobody's thinking they're
going to win that.
Or I'll show you motherfuckers and
you go out there and put on a show.
I also think it was part of a man at
that part of existing Amanda too. Is it?
When she's the underdog, it's just
less pressure on her. So again,
as another distraction away. So she's just
like, all right, watches the underdog.
Watch how I fuck y'all. Y'All put
pressure on me to be the change, you know,
to win this fight easily.
You know, I think she can
hold back a little bit. Well,
she was this favorite
against Raquel Pennington.
She's a favor against for cal and I think
that was one of our best performance.
But Raquel hung in there a little
bit, you know, she did a little bit,
but she didn't had a threat.
We kind of had around her two and I don't
think she did. She had a chat around.
You think she went around?
She,
she took a man down at one point and had
around maybe? I don't think so. I mean,
I don't get it.
I don't think he was,
I don't have to think of man it was in
trouble or anything, but, hm. Interesting.
I think Amanda won every round. If I
was, if I'm recalling it correctly,
I'd have to go back and look at it. But
I remember thinking it was like a slow,
steady beat down. It was, I mean it was,
I mean it was pretty, it was convincing.
It was pretty easy fight for her,
but what the fuck is what's left for her?
Especially like there's what one
legit featherweight size wise,
it's Meegan Anderson,
but Meagan got exposed a little bit by
Holly because Holly took her down and
really dominated her in the clinch and
got her Kinda to the ground at will and
I'm sure she's tightened up a lot
of that, but Nah, she doesn't.
She's,
she's too slow.
You think so a lot of
people don't understand like
speed is everything in this
game really more so than size. That's
why I was saying about I cutting weight.
Speed is key in this game and a lot of
people get exposed when they're not fast
enough. You know, because,
and I don't mean necessarily even just
speed and physically I guess heavyweight
speed physically, but like
speed and decision making
speed, all that speed is key.
And I don't think Megan
Hamson is going to be,
have enough speed to deal with Amanda.
Well,
you also have the thing to Megan
Anderson when she fought Holly Holm,
that was her UFC debut.
Right.
And that is that Octagon Shanae
legit. It's fun. We've all had,
we've all had it.
You see that moment where the bright
lights hit you for the first time and
you're like, whoa. And then also her
first fight is against Holly fucking home.
I know. Jesus Christ. Yeah.
I mean that's as experienced as you
get. I mean, Holly is, she's Woo.
She like an 18 time world boxing champion.
Yeah.
She was like 27 and two.
She has one of,
until Amanda knocked outside board,
she had the greatest highlight reel Kayo
and a championship fight. Well yeah,
in a championship fight because I
think that a Jessica on drudge when she
knocked out Catalina Catalina
Kovacevich yeah, that was,
that was a bigger than
knockout then. Yay. One, well,
not bigger. It was right up there.
Yeah, it was right up there.
But Amanda just took the fucking cake. It
was like, she's like out, that's my bed.
She's like,
you think he saw the best women's MMA KL
ever hold my beer because it's who she
did it too. I know. I know. Ah, it's
everything. And she did it as someone,
I mean, I ain't gonna lie
man. I was surprised. As
much as I love Amanda, she's,
you know, she's, I hold
her dear to my heart.
I was even surprised who she
throws bricks. I know she throws,
you know what she's like, she's like a
bowling ball on the end of a rope. Yep.
Boom, boom. But, but if you,
have you ever spent time around her and
hung out a little bit out the, you know,
at the fights when she's not
fighting backstage? Very friendly.
But this is what I'm saying. You know,
like a lot of fighters are like, you know,
they can have kind of
aggressive personalities. She's
nothing like that. Right?
I mean she likes to sit at home like she,
she's got an Instagram picture,
like she's cutting the grass
and sand and flip flops.
I mean he's just so
carefree. She just like, she
likes to play with her dogs in the
backyard and well I was upset when she was
fighting Ronda that all the promos
were about Rhonda coming back. Yeah,
that pissed her off. I said
before that, before when she,
when Rhonda was about to fight Holly Holm,
I said that I disagreed with that fight.
I said,
I really think Amanda Nunez is the most
dangerous challenge for Ronda. I see.
Cause Amanda has a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
black belt and her hands or what's really
scary, like when Rhonda has to close
the distance to get ahold of you,
when she gets you on the ground,
she's armed Barney.
I'm going to felt like Amanda
like sizes up with her.
But that's the most dangerous
challenge in my opinion.
But then Holly knocked her out and then
when you saw Amanda Knock Out Rhonda,
I was like, well this, how did you
guys not see this coming? Like,
this is not a good match up.
And you,
you spent the entire Promo talking about
this one person who's not the champion,
who's coming back after
a devastating knockout.
And then you didn't show anything about
the one person who is the champion,
who's the first openly gay
women's champion in the
history of the sport, right?
She's, she's the first
gay UFC champion. Yup.
And she's a fucking destroyer.
I mean she's exciting as shit and all
you're showing is Rhonda pacing around her
mansion.
You know,
Rhonda getting excited about this fight
and thinking I'm going to go out there
and like Jesus Christ and then
backstage here was what, it was crazy.
I was listening to these agents
talk because Rhonda is fights.
One of the things that was interesting
about it was a, she was such a force,
such a cult of personality that she had
all these agents and shit around like
all these,
like it was all agent to find backstage.
So I hear these guys talking and one
agent Dork is talking to the other agent
door and he goes, who's
Ronda fighting? And he's,
I'm paraphrasing, but it, his base
that he said, I don't know who she is,
but she's a victim. Like I don't know
who it is, what's called our facility.
So they really thought that that
dot. Good idea. They had no idea.
I mean, look, that's what
they were hoping. They were
hoping that Rhonda winds,
because she's his gigantic superstar.
Like if Ronda comes back,
beats Amanda Nunez wins a title back.
Rematches Holly Holm. Pete's Holly Holm.
Yes,
she's back.
But instead she gets
marked and 48 seconds.
I mean Amanda just, and I was
saying to them afterwards, like, I,
this is what I was telling you, like
how the fuck are you not promoting her?
Like [inaudible] who she just did.
If you put equal time promoting her,
now you got a new star in your hands.
Instead,
the story is Rhonda Rousey got smashed.
The story's not Amanda Smashwords.
Even afterwards they didn't,
they didn't pick up what Amanda. Yes.
Yeah, I agree. It's crazy to me. Like,
it's crazy to think that they thought
that this was going to be Rhonda come back
to start him because, and I
thought you to break down. I said,
I don't know if you saw it,
but cause I scout or Amanda its
opponents and I do the breakdown.
I come up with strategies for her
and after scout and Rhonda, I said,
there's going to be easy fight for
you. And I told her that. I said,
this isn't gonna be easy.
And it turned out to be easy and it
just surprises me that they thought that
this was going to be the come
out party for Rhonda. I don't,
I didn't talk to Tina about it.
I told Dana before,
I thought it was a
terrible mantra for Rhonda.
But that was before the Holly Holm fight
and no, no, no. She got this. Well,
he was saying you need, I don't know. He,
he thought that I was saying that Holly
Holm, Ronda was going to beat Holly.
I mean, well I'm not saying that's easy
either. That's a tough fight too. Yeah.
But the thing about
Amanda is punching power.
How he's not knowing for punching power.
She's known for speed or kicks her
timing. Her technique. Her, her toughness.
Yeah. She's known for all her
athleticism. Physical strength. Yeah.
She's known for all those things.
She's not known just to go in there
and blast girls. Yeah, like Amanda,
the last people.
She puts them into another dimension.
She's different in that respect, but they
didn't concentrate on that at all. Mike,
how are you not concentrating on this
destroyer that Rhonda is about to face,
but show them you should take fight and
people would just be like, Jesus. Yeah,
beats stuff. Fuck out of her. And
then it's triangles around. I'm like,
and you're like, God, I know.
That's why it surprised me that
they slept on Amanda. I'm like,
how y'all sleeping on her? Cause
it's Hollywood, man. They, they, the,
the narrative that they had
was Rhonda was the best ever,
which she was when she was
the best until she fell.
But if you looked at the way she
fought Holly, this is my opinion.
I feel like there was a million things
going on other than just fighting.
There's a million things going on. There's
movie offers, this television shows,
there's everybody's,
there's agents in deals and books
and all this shit is happening.
And then she's with Edmond. Okay. She's,
she's not an American top team. She's not,
she's not dealing with a bunch of people
that are being a hundred percent honest
and people who have a deep background of
experience of training worldclass mixed
martial arts fighters who recognize that
the holes in her game, the strengths,
the weakness,
someone like you who can like categorize
who she is and had a molder, there's no,
there's no great minds
behind her orchestrating.
This is just some guy telling her, oh,
you're great, you're getting better.
And she's holding him Manson shakes
great on the meds and she does a great on
the minute.
There's times when she didn't look too
bad on the meds when she fucked Batchko
Hey, I'm pat pat, Pat, pat,
and she's in Brazil. You like
damn fucking kick box. Yeah.
Right. But that's, there's a
big difference between that.
And then being able to do that on
Amanda Nunez is a big difference. Yeah.
And you need world class coaching.
You need someone who's going to recognize
there's hiccups in what you're doing.
There's, there's miss, there's
stages missing all. I mean,
one of the things that Greg Jackson's
him when they prepared her for Holly Holm
or per prepared Holly Holm for, they
said, if you look at how she, she engages,
it's always grab with the left arm.
It's always grabbing the left arm and
they were just move out to the side and if
you lock when she ducked under Rhonda as
punch and she went to that right side,
she's always going to that right side
and then boom, there's that head kick.
That might've been one of the
funniest moments in the history. Okay.
Duck de UFC was, he ducked that punch
and she hit the knee and hit the fence.
Did I ain't gonna lie.
That was pretty funny.
Well it was indicative of like some
serious errors and preparation and also I
think the way she fought was just so
reckless. Just charge for champions.
Don't fight like that. Right. But
I mean, but it's understandable.
I'm going to say this in her defense is
understandable because that's who she
was at a time.
Like say she was the greatest ever.
So she didn't expect to
ever be in this position.
But true,
she got an opera,
she had an opportunity to correct
it and she dropped the ball on that.
Well here's the thing about Ronda, she's
very smart. She's very, very smart,
but she's also very strong minded.
And if wield,
I believe there's probably very few
people that can pull her aside and go,
you got to listen to me because you get
knocked the fuck out. This is real. Okay,
you're the greatest.
You're the greatest ever have of course.
But this is not how you do this camp.
This is not how you prepare for
this person. We need more. We need,
we need different than,
we don't need you to sparring boxing
with people cause you're not boxing.
You're not going to have these gloves on.
We Need World Class MMA coaching.
We need to figure out how to shoot and
landed double. You can't just be grabbing,
clenching cause that shit doesn't work
on everybody. Right. And, and, and like,
she almost got choked
out by Liz Carmouche.
Remember that Liz had her
back a little bit. Yeah. That
she was ahead of the, yeah.
Rhonda just gutted it
out and got out of it.
She's such a great grappler in
her neck are so God damn strong.
She gutted it out and made it out of
there. But that was dangerous. Yeah.
Her job was fucked up after that
fight for a long time. Really? Yeah.
From just getting cranked, just
getting, I mean, Liz Carmouche is, uh,
she's, she's just strong.
I saw her, the ballet,
they bitchy strong as strong as fuck.
And she almost pulled it off. I mean,
she almost pulled it off from that.
That headlock position is a very
dangerous position, right? Yeah.
You headlock someone and their,
their legs go around and if that head
pops out were on your back. Yeah.
It's the worst position if you can't pull
it off. Yeah. And that was her thing.
Her thing was headlock people flipping
into the ground and it worked on almost
everybody, but it's like, Ooh, eventually
he's going to catch up eventually. Was in,
maybe, maybe not, but the phone,
the thing is you need, look,
you could look at a guy like mighty
mouse who we both agree is like the best
expression of mixed martial arts talent.
That guy does everything.
He shoots doubles. He'll
ankle pick, he'll fucking,
he'll hit you with the flying arm bar.
He'll do whatever the fuck he wants.
He could do everything you can't have,
like you can't have only one approach
to success because as soon as someone
figures out,
oh she grabs it that left arm,
I'm just going to get
the fuck out of there.
I'm not going to be anywhere near that
left arm. Right. Yeah. Well that's,
and I was saying about speed too.
Like when you look at like got
like mighty mouse, like yeah,
he's doing all that with speed and the
precision of his technique is just like
unstoppable, ridiculous
speed. I grabbed him once,
just joking around backstage and he
hit me with two knees to the body.
I was like,
Geez,
it was so fast. I was like, my brain
is too slow to even calculate that.
You know that, that kind of
the Brit pop, I was like, oh,
you imagine the BDN Henry said,
who when he fought him and had to
experience that and re the first fight in
particular realize like, oh Jesus,
I know, but Henry Henry came back,
I was just made a joke. He
made an adjustment. But I
think in a rematch, I think,
I think he's a beats him in a rematch.
Do you think Dj beats him in the rematch?
I wonder if, because it was very
close. Very close. What I'm saying,
it was a vague again,
eventually it catches up to you to
get caught up to how did he win?
He won by taking him down. He
didn't win by dominating on, right.
It's not like mighty mouse beat him. He
destroyed him. Right. It's like he could,
he has a much better chance of finishing.
So who though then?
So who doe has a finishing? Yeah, no
doubt. Yeah. So that's why I think Dj,
if they fought again,
I think DJ finishes and the only guy I
think gives DJ a problem. He might not,
you might not know who. Um, well
we haven't seen Tj at one 25 yet,
but uh, killed you whore. Gucci. Really?
Oh, mighty beat. Or Gucci. He did. Yeah,
but that was, that was years ago. Really?
Yeah. That was years ago. Yarn Barn.
He dominated them and then
he did, he did, but fuck
this guy. But this guy has got
speed coaching heart, Gucci. I,
I've worked with them a little bit,
but I'm not like his main guy. Right.
But this guy has got speed. Unbelievable
speed. It's got serious knockout power.
Serious knockout power.
I have to say. Yeah,
I believe you. I think he gets shit.
I think he gives, I think he gives Dj.
I'm not saying that he will beat him
if they were fine, I'm just saying,
but he could,
he could.
I would thought Scoggins was a real threat
when I first saw Scoggins. I was like,
he should've done, he should've been.
Yeah. I was like this guy with that style,
that karate style,
but also can wrestle.
And Lena had to do it more with
coaching and anything. Now,
and I hate to say that because he's
probably got a coach right now and listen
and go down.
But I really do think that it's like
maybe not really filling in his holes.
You know, cause he's got a
lot to work with. Like you
said, like that karate style.
He can wrestle.
I'm sure he's got decent submissions,
but he's probably got some holes.
Coaching is so critical.
Coaching can take a guy who could be a
journeymen and turned them into a world
champion. There's, there's, there's
this pivot, like the fights you choose,
the things you do when you
do them, you know, when,
when to say no to things, when to say yes
to things. Yeah. Guidance and coaching.
But the problem with fighters,
man is so damn hard headed. Yeah.
You have to be right. Yeah. You have
crazy beliefs. Yeah you do. You got to,
you have to. And that's like, like
we were saying earlier, like Amanda,
she hard headed sometimes, you know, like,
but that's what got her, her success.
But most fighters are hard and are
in a position to be hardheaded.
And that's like the hard part. It's
like you tried to tell them, listen,
you need to listen to me right
now. And like, no, I got this.
And then their careers just,
it's crazy cause that's what made them a
fighter in the first place where I tell
else to fuck all that father beat
their ass. They left the house
and there's 16 fucked you.
I'll show the world
that happened to me
as I have to me.
And then next thing I know I'm out there
fucking get in the cage. I feel bad
for dudes who didn't get dumped. I do.
Why that? Cause it's good for you.
Yeah, it taught me a lot, man.
I remember my girlfriend in
high school and dumped me.
I was devastated for months.
Just devastated.
But then I realized like what the
Fuck is wrong with me? And I thought,
imagine if I married that girl.
Ooh Magic.
I've had kids with her and Ooh.
And every day was just
torture her bitching at me
and controlling and oh I got
light, I got off light. Well
here's one for you to enjoy.
Well same thing happened to me. I
got dumped in high school. Yeah.
The girl started dating another dude.
I ended up hitting this motherfucker
in here with a ranch of rent. Yeah.
I had a hit the fucking hit with a wrench.
Why'd you hit him in the
head with a wrench? He pissed
me off. Oh, he pissed me.
He made me so mad.
Did he make you mad cause he was banging
the girl or do you make me mad on top
of that? Oh, on top of that.
Yeah. So I ended up hitting him.
Then I ended up going to jail to him and
I ended up doing 52 weekends in jail.
Damn. But within that time, every week,
every weekend I had to go in on Friday,
four year, come out on Sunday for a year.
So I couldn't leave.
I couldn't leave my city.
So in that time I taught myself how
to fight. That's why I'm here today.
Wow. And during the weekends? No. So, uh,
during the week, cause I couldn't
leave so I would just, I work.
And then me and Paul Rodriguez, he fought
20 to Susan. You see 30 to me and him,
we trained and we taught ourselves
how to fight in the backyard,
watching videotapes. Wow. Tony D'souza,
the originator of the Peruvian necktie.
Yep. Yep. That's what I came from.
Is that really what I came for
us? He's Peruvian. No kitten.
That's where it came from.
That Peruvian necktie is a mother fucker.
That's a great move.
That was Tony Shit. Yeah.
I incorporate that and on
one of my systems, man,
I loved that movie was a hell
of a grappler. Yeah. Yeah.
So he ended up choking
out a Paul Rodriguez,
UFC 32 and I was in that.
I got knocked out by Bj.
Wow.
But it all happened because I got dumped.
Wow. That's crazy. He hit him
with a ranch, Huh? Yeah. Yeah.
I know. I ain't proud of
it. Yeah. How old were you?
17 yeah. The frontal cortex not even
fully formed. That's what I'm saying.
Like making dumb decisions.
You 17 like you with the girl is 17 for
two years. That's half your damn life.
I know, right. You know? So you thinking
that's the one also like the heartbreak.
If you're not accustomed to it,
like everybody experiences heartbreak.
Somebody breaks, breaks up with
you, like I feel like shit.
But then you call your friends up
like, come on man, we'll go out,
get a couple of drinks and then you
have a couple of dreams I, I whatever.
And then you get a text from
an x and you're like, oh
yeah, here it goes back in the
game and you'll be all right.
That girl. Yeah, I'm, I'm, I,
I think it's good to get broken up with
it is you learn, you know, you learn,
you also,
you learned
why you were annoying to her.
You know,
like there's some stupid shit that
you're doing and you don't even realize
you're doing,
but you're doing it and then it becomes
a pattern and you do it again and again
and again. Then finally they'd dump you
and then you get some reflection time.
You're like, Ugh, why am I so annoying?
I remember you said talk about that
before about like self reflection and
awareness and like that's so important,
man.
It's critical being real to yourself and
aware and being aware of where you are
in relation to everybody else in the
world. I try to coach myself d yeah.
I tried to sit down with myself and when
I do like meditation sessions and Shit,
I try to pretend that I'm like a coach
and I'm looking at myself. Honestly.
I was like, all right dude, you ain't
spending nearly enough time doing this.
Well you need to fix that. Like,
hey, you're right. And they're like,
no bath and that's great.
I had to start doing that.
It's a skill like you have to like
develop it because I think that's part of
most people's problems is that they're
not aware of where they are in life.
You know, one other product problem
that people have to his momentum,
they get caught up in momentum of doing
stupid shit or momentum of being lazy or
momentum of eating bad or
drinking or whatever it is
that does. That's bad. Yeah.
And they can't break that. You get caught
up and you need to stop reflection.
And that's one of the reasons why I think
meditation is so important. Oh yeah.
I meditate every day. Do you? Yeah.
How do you do it? What do you do? Um,
I lay down and close my eyes.
So what I'll do is I'll start with some
self talk first just to get me going.
Self talk,
positive affirmation statements.
Just lay down quiet for about 10 minutes
example. Like what kind of self talk?
Like what do you, what kind of positive
affirmation, you know, just um, uh,
you know, I appreciate life,
appreciate where I'm at. Yeah. I'm,
I'm gonna keep going. I'm doing
my, you know, just um, every day.
Strive to be better, you know, or I'll
get even more detailed, you know. Um,
you know, uh, you know,
I do a lot of entertained Chad to
do a lot of entertainment stuff,
so I want to get better at public
speaking, so I'll, you know,
trying to talk myself until a
little stand up. Yeah. Do standup.
I do every so often. Very funny. Ah,
already funding, not at the diamond bar.
Last time I was there. That's tough. That
time. Bars sketchy. Is it really good?
That makes me feel better. Yeah. Yeah.
Jeremy Pivot said the same thing. He said,
yeah, I bombed. I was like
not when I was at. Yeah. But
um, but not so I've tried to,
you know, I'm intelligent, I'm
smart, I'm going to make it,
I got this, I'm making
lots of money. You know,
I tried to talk myself
into that and then I,
and then for the next 20 minutes or so
I just sit in silence and just let all
that Soakin do you concentrate on your
breathing or anything? Cause you know,
like if I get distracted like noise or
whatever at center, back to my breathing.
Yeah.
That's the big one for me.
I've tried a bunch of
different styles of meditation,
but one that I liked the best,
especially in the tank is a breathing.
You bring shorts with you
today. Yeah. No, but yeah.
Have you done the tank?
No. What is that? You never heard
about it? No, I never done that.
You could do it today. I want to go time.
Okay. We'll set it up. I want to do this.
Yeah, I try it out here. I'll show it to
you as someone assessed on by some tank.
Yeah. What is that? Yeah. I
don't even know what that is.
There was only one guy who's
uses tank other than me.
And Jamie's been sneaking here in the
middle of the night is a Dan Harris from
good morning America. He's used it
cause he's a, he's a big meditator.
I set him up with it, but it's amazing.
It's a tank that's filled up with,
it's a flotation tank. It's a, it was
made by this guy named John Lilly who was,
uh, a psychedelic adventure and a
pioneer, an interspecies communication.
He was a working on trying
to communicate with dolphins.
He was take acid and getting the tank
and take acid and give dolphins acid and
he was out of his fucking mind.
Lily was a real trip.
You know, his books are amazing. He
was a, uh, like a super genius who was,
um, he was going through his career
during this psychedelic revolution,
like the Timothy Leary's and
all those people have the time.
Terrence Mckenna and he did.
He was trying to figure out a way to
separate the mind from the body. And one,
one thing that he realized
is like sensory input.
Like you and I are sitting here, you're,
you're, but it's touching the chair.
Your feet are touching the floor.
You feel the table, all that stuff.
Those are signals. Those signals go to
your brain, your brain's processing that.
And the way I,
the analogy that I was making is
imagine if you and I were having this
conversation, but right over there
there was a dude with a jackhammer that,
that that data,
we can still talk,
but it would be super distracting and
maybe wouldn't be able to express yourself
the right way because you would be
taking in the input of all that noise.
So we'd be like,
hey man,
let's go talk over there where it's
quiet and you go talk over there.
And it would be easier because
it'd be no distraction.
Well your whole body's a distraction.
Everything is a distraction sitting down.
So distraction the lights in
this room or a distraction.
The fact that Jamie's here and the tables
here and you're taking into account
all the objects around you and
this is all input without input,
your brain becomes a very different thing.
So when the tank,
the water is heated to 94 degrees,
that's the temperature of
the surface of your skin.
Then there's a thousand pounds
of Epsom salts in the water.
So which is really good because your body
gets the magnesium from that but also
really good because you
float like a motherfucker.
You lie in that thing and half the, your
body is above the surface of the water.
You're just floating cause there's
so much salt, it's so dense.
And then you lay back and then he
closed the door. Total darkness.
You don't see any that you open your
eyes just as dark is when you close your
eyes. Then total silence,
your ears are underwater.
You just lay in there floating in this
water. And once you, once you send her,
cause you kind of wiggle around a little
bit cause of waters swishing you cause
you step into it and you know you gotta
you gotta let the water settle in,
relax and then let your arms settle and
you can't tell where the water is and
where the error is.
Cause it's all the same temperature
cause the water's the same temperatures.
Your skin, you don't feel the water
after awhile and you get relaxed.
So then when I'm in the tank,
then I concentrate on my breathing on
concentrating is in with good out with the
bad in with the good out with the bad.
I'm just concentrated in breathing
through my nose, out through the mouth
and I'm only letting myself
concentrate on the nose.
But I'll think about stupid shit like oh
I gotta clean my closet and I got to do
this and I haven't been to yoga in a
week and I have all those thoughts.
Eventually will go away. I just got
to go [inaudible] don't do that.
Don't do that. Don't think about that.
Like man I need my thick by Lisa.
My car's up soon and you
can't let those venire. Right.
Just got to think of the breath
breathing in through the nose,
out through the mouth. And you ne. I
never in all my times of doing this,
I've never had a pure experience where I
didn't have to fight off those thoughts
and something for sure.
Think they all.
One day you'll get to a point where
you just hold that in and a half.
Never had that. Never been
there. Never. I try all the time.
But when you have the absence,
an absence of any sensory input,
your brain becomes supercharged.
You could see your life much more clearly.
There's nothing there but
you and your thoughts.
Your mind is detached from your body.
And this is what Lilly figured out.
He figured out a way to separate
the body from the mind. Damn.
But you show how I'm a float.
Cause you know black people don't swim
to announce when we either really sink
like a rock. All right, good.
Yeah. Did I send like a rock?
I barely could tread water.
Barely even in the ocean.
I struggle trying to die.
Your dense man, I'm sure.
But that thing is so there's
so much salt in that water.
Everybody floats every afloat.
Yeah.
It's basically like it has
to be stirred up every day.
There's a pump that
constantly circulates it.
It's got all these old water purification
tanks that are attached to it.
There's purification filters rather for
like, uh, they're, they're these giant,
the guy who made it is my friend crash
who runs the float lab in Venice,
which is the premier
distributor of float tanks.
They make the best shit on the planet
bar none. He's a mad scientist.
When you see the whole setup back there,
you realize like there's so much salt
in it that it has to constantly be
recycled and move through.
Otherwise it will crystallize and
you get these giant salt rock,
so he gets pulled out of it. So it's
going to constantly, you're gonna float,
you'll float. Look, it's
going to be beautiful.
It will be like that baby in
Nirvana just floating around there.
You're going to love it. It's amazing.
I definitely want to try. Yeah, it's,
but I feel like att could benefit
from having one of those down there.
It's a really good thing for fighters.
It's really good thing for relaxing
like Epson salt baths. Right.
And that's does giant for just loosening
your muscles and relaxing good therapy
after you train.
That's the more Epsom salts and you're
ever going to get in a fucking bathtub.
Yeah. That is real Epsom salts. Do you
put that thing around a bunch of fighters?
This Stasha Miss Jason in their
[inaudible] going to steal it.
Att has a, you guys have dorms too,
right? We got dorms. That's crazy.
That's great though.
I mean it really,
it's really helpful to the guys because
we got all the times we got like
presents and Dagestani.
Yeah.
And Greg live in there, so it's
crazy. Yeah. Yeah. It's amazing.
I mean, it's good though, man. I mean
it's uh, it's the best gym on the planet.
Can't complain. But certainly
one of them. I mean, yeah.
In terms of the actual overall facility,
I don't think there's another facility
like it on earth. No, it's number one.
Right. In terms of the size and size
and all what Dan Lambert has done.
Like fucking God blessed Dan Lambert guys
put more money into the development of
MMA than anybody other than the fatigue.
And there's,
there's absolutely no doubt about that.
I can't think of another guy who has
been around as long and as pumped more of
his own money into just helping
guys. And he's such a good guy. Yeah.
He's such a good guy
in a fucking real man.
A man's man,
but not just a rich guy that's throwing
his money and he fucking trains,
trains his black belt legit
like he had in his house.
He had a gym and he used to have all
the dudes come over back in the day.
Moral boost to mice and the come over.
Logan are brothers be that training with
him. He's a legit, yeah, he loves it.
I mean legitimately loves the sport. Like
when Amanda One and he was in the cage,
he was so happy he passed.
She had a tears crying and shit.
He say he's a legit dude,
man. He's very legit.
But what he's done is amazing because he
had an amazing gym already and then he
built this gigantic fucking facility,
built it from the ground up specifically
like, yeah, you're right. Yeah.
Bought the land and built the
gym on top of it. Fuck does that.
Everyone else just goes to a
warehouse and go, yeah, okay,
we'll set up the cage over here.
No, he designed it. I know.
I wish they had designed it a little
differently though because I would like to
have seen the um, the pros
separated. How so? Um,
from like general population. Oh,
I see what you're saying. You know,
like that's not that it might, I mean
it's easy to look back, hindsight and say,
yeah, it was better if they were
separated. But like now it's kind of like,
you kind of want to separate
your pros from like, you know,
five year olds taking class. You know,
you're right. You know, uh, you know,
our Lawsky walking around with no shirt
on and hairy chest bumping into like
some old lady who was there with her
grandson. You know, you look at his nose,
he's like, yeah, that's a bit scary,
you know. So I mean it just, you know,
my selfish and this is like,
yeah man,
we need to get to stay on the
side so we can, yeah. Yeah.
Well how many regular folks do you have
coming into the gym? I regular folks?
Yeah. Oh, I mean it's a whole thing
of like regular folks. Real. Yeah.
So like classes for little kids,
classes for little kids,
regular Jujitsu, banging
out and the same, I mean,
we do a good enough job of having
to bang out sessions in the morning,
like at night, you know, it
was still running to, you know,
the fighters are still
running around acting a fool.
Is there good pictures of what it looks
like online? Yeah. Yeah. I think Google,
American top team, top team,
the new gym in particular.
Fucking incredible facility, man. Yeah.
How much of that shit cost? I don't know.
I don't know. I just a landlord to
think about it. I hear that place.
I mean it's,
you know,
south Florida too. So yeah,
it's expensive as shit that,
that's a amazing facility too.
And they have a giant,
well how big the math
space says holy shit.
Stadium stairs or seats did they have,
um,
they have a whole
strength and conditioning.
So I've on that go on the other end of
that where you see that Manhattan, they,
the condition is not over there and wow,
that's amazing.
Yeah. I mean that's what
everybody hopes for. I mean,
how many people must move down there
just to be able to train there?
You know,
honestly we don't,
I mean we do get a lot of people that
move down there just to train there.
But I think we do better with guys
who come and just do camp billing.
Yeah. How come? I Dunno.
I Dunno. We just seem to,
cause we can provide for them. We
have dorms. Yeah. So we have dorms,
so it seems to work out better for most
guys where they live somewhere else and
then they want to just come do camps.
They come for six weeks a stay in a dorm
for six weeks. We tightened them up.
Boom. Yeah. Does that
all lot of people do to Robbie
was doing that right now.
Robbie actually moved down. He moved
down, but yeah, robbing move now. Um,
Tyron was doing that,
right? Not really sweet.
Tyron comes down whenever
he feels like it,
but he does his camps it in Milwaukee
wit and we'd go to Duke. Roufus is,
what do you think about him fighting
it loose man? I like loose man.
It was great fun. Yeah. I've always liked
loose mine. I like him as a fighter.
I don't know him as a person,
but as a fighter he's fucking
terrifying. Yeah. He's,
he's super smart. He's really
good. He's very versatile. Briefly.
He can do everything. So that's why I
think it's more of a challenge than Colby.
Yeah.
Because Uzman spin brings more to
the table striking power wise power.
And the Colby thing though was in
terms of like a marketing fight,
like I felt like that was a
very good fight marketing wise.
I think they could have had that
fight stand alone. Yeah. You know,
I don't wonder why they didn't do
though. They I think, but you know,
don't think it could have
had that fight standalone.
They didn't need John Jones and Anthony
Smith. I think Colby talks a lot of shit.
Other than that, he doesn't just talk
shit when the cameras are on a bet.
He Talk Shit all the time.
Like we had Kobe and camp sometimes and
like I remember when he first started
fighting and we was always cordial,
but now, you know what I'm saying?
Like I don't even talk to him. He, he
goes his way in a gym. We pass each other.
Why is that? Just as
awkward. Yeah. You know,
it's like he's talking about my homeboy
tiring, you know, 10 he's dogging him out,
you know? And, but you also know
that he's got to do that. Yeah,
I knew it was going to get the fight.
I'll say this too.
Like even though I know that
I'm still like happy for him,
I'm happy did he was able to
get to success. He's gotten,
whether it was from talking or not,
they still wanting to fights.
He's still beat dos Anjos and he
beat those on Jill's convincingly.
He beat Joe site. Yes. So he's still won.
He talked a lot and I'm happy for him
but, but I was just hoping that, you know,
it's time to face the music.
Yeah, you deserve. Does ass woman.
Well I think the UFC offered him
loose mon and I think he said no.
I see. I think he said he wants
to fight Tyron and they'll like,
you're not in any position to the side.
And even though they had promised
him a shot at the title before,
Ben Aspirin said,
did you believe Dana white
ass good tweeted to him. And
he said, I love Ben. He's,
he's the most ruthless when
it comes to Twitter. Yeah.
He's the most ruthless honesty.
That's hilarious. To check it.
Check onto your skirt,
man. Ben, I'll get you.
It's a great fight though.
Uzman entire and I'm not mad at the fight.
I do kind of wish that Colby was getting
a shot because I want to see that fight
and I don't know if I will ever
see that fight. Tyron. Tyrons Matt,
he doesn't like Colby.
He doesn't like degree yet.
And angry Tyron is a scary human being.
He might be the fastest, hardest hitting
170 pounds of that's ever lived. Yeah.
Who the fuck is faster than tiring?
Who the fuck hits harder?
You look at his fights with Wonderboy.
Wonderboy recognizes one of the
greatest strikers in the sport ever.
The only person who got hurt and those
fights was Wonderboy. The same thing with,
with Darren till Darren tills
a motherfucker on the feet.
Tyrant shut that shit up quick.
Blam one big right hand drop.
Some beats the fuck out of him
and chokes the shit out of him.
Well here's the thing man, is
it, you know it's coming to Yup.
Like every like you just can't
prepare for it. It's so fast. Yeah.
You'd know it's coming. You're like, here
it comes. Here it comes. Oh, there it is.
Well you got to engage.
And the thing about Tyron too is
he's intelligent and patient. Yeah.
And he'll just,
he'll just hang around on the outside.
He'll hang around the house. Come on.
Yeah. No, you want to do, make a mistake.
Make a mistake, a mistake. The
Wonderboy fights, like you were saying,
all those fights are boring.
You have to fight Wonderboy that way.
Yeah.
How else do you fight them?
There's not another way to fight him
because it's like another way you're going
to lose. This is the way to find
them. You have to fight that way.
If you don't fight that way,
you get fucked up.
If you fight the way you know
fucking Jake Ellenberger yeah,
yeah. You, you can wheel
kicked in the head. Yeah.
You fight the way Hendrick's fondom
yeah. Fuck you. Fuck you fucked up. Yeah,
you gotta fight that way.
You got to stay on the outside.
You can't give into those faints
and he's going to hit you with them.
Little pity paths and tips and taps cause
he's just trying to tag you and touch
you for the big ones
coming in. And he's, he's,
he's elusive and he's clever and
he's a lot quicker than you think.
He also bends at the waist like
a god Damn Kolbe. Yay. Woo.
He's very good at bending at the waist
and then coming back with punches.
He's a dangerous fighter and Woodley
fought him the perfect way and he did it
twice. Yeah. And people are like, oh,
that's boring. But that's Wonderboy.
That's what to be exciting.
And you get fucked up or you fight
in a cautious, intelligent way.
And the fans, boo. See, I see Joe,
I got you all wrong. Oh, sorry.
I thought you hated Tyra.
Why would I hate talking?
I don't know what I'm saying because
like everybody kind of always had hiring
things. Everybody hates time. Yeah.
Maybe we talk now. We never go now.
The Shit I'm talking about
Tyron, it's all positive. We,
we've never actually talked about it,
but um,
but it just seems like everybody wants to
jump on him no matter what. No. Yeah, no.
I mean, no, I, I think he's, if he's not
the greatest welterweight of all time,
he's in the running
cause like Matt Hughes,
I feel like you have to give legend
respect to his. Matt Hughes was the first.
Matt Hughes was a powerful wrestler.
That was the first guy
to embrace submissions.
You only go when Matt Hughes beat George
Saint Pierre and he hit him with that
far side arm bar. That spirit. Yeah,
that's some high level shit that
we fucked up. Frank Trigg twice.
It took his back and strangle them.
Matt Hughes was the first high
level wrestler, tough as shit,
strong as a God damn gorilla who embraced
submissions and he and and did it in a
really intelligent and you know,
effective way. He was like,
I feel like he was the first day,
so you got to give him his props.
He's the lead legend props.
Then George Saint Pierre is number one
after that because George St Pierre was
the fucking full package.
He could do everything.
He figured out how to beat everybody
and he beat everybody for a long time.
Then this Woodley and I feel like I
look at Woodley and George St Pierre.
I feel Woodley matches up very well
with George Saint Pierre and I would,
I would have loved to see, I
think Georgia's still, look,
if you look the way George
looked against Michael Bisping,
he still looks like he's in his
prime and he hasn't, he didn't even,
he fought very well in that fight and I
think his submissions are probably even
better the way he took Michael
Bisping's back and choked him.
Like motherfuckers still got it. Well,
you know, he's working when Donna her.
So like that guy is a wizard
wizard. Yeah, that fight.
I'm very curious to see and I feel like
if George really wanted to come back
with a big challenge and have a,
a big gigantic,
you know,
epic Superfight I feel like Tyron Woodley
a deserves it and B matches up with
him very well. I mean, know, that's
a very interesting fight to me.
The other interesting fight to me with
George has could beep if he could really
get down to 155 pounds, which he says
he can't. That's super interesting.
Yeah. I'll say, what do you think about
George and Ben? I like that too. Yeah,
I like that too. I looked at a luck ban
against, I like Bennigan's could beep.
Yeah, it got a lot. I liked that
a lot because Ben is bigger,
he's strong as shit and you don't get
better wrestling Katrin credentials now
the problem like what MMA is like,
you get all these fights,
he's like fantasy fights that you want
to make but you can't make them. Yeah.
Because a lot of politics involved,
but at least everybody's under the roof.
Right? Like before it was like when
fader was over in pride like God damn,
I want to get him over here.
I wanted to get him over there so bad.
But that never happened.
You know? And then when he
finally made it to strike force, he was
kind of, it wasn't the same guy anymore.
He had had some miles on him,
long fights.
Slu didn't look physically the same as
he looked like back when he fought like
Mirko Cro, cop or Nogueira. I
mean he was a God damn destroyer.
Yeah. I always wanted to
see him fight in the UFC.
I think he could have been UFC champion. I
really do. Yeah. Back in his prime. Yeah,
for sure. Cause he was like the first
dude. It was really like mauling guys.
He was mauling and like
what his ground and pound.
And that's something that they're like,
I don't think with the exception of cubby,
nobody else has actually recreated the
type of violence did he put when he got
on top of people,
hurl himself into you and throwing bombs,
he would fuck people up,
man.
And it also could catch some missions
in a blink of an eye half his back yet.
And when we fought Randleman random and
sent him flying suplexes and he lands on
his head,
he lands on his neck and the shoulder
and then seconds later he catches rent.
Randleman Kamora and physics.
He's like, watch this
now. Watch my turn. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Fado was demand like it sucks.
Like this generation of MMA fans that
we have today don't have that type of
history. Yeah. And they don't know.
They don't know, like the real fate or,
and they see him now and Bella
tour and just thinking, yeah,
you're not getting the chance to
see the real faint or you know,
you're not seeing fade or from
the early days, you know. Yeah.
He was, he was so good and he was so
fast too. Yeah. You know what I mean?
He was just everything. He had it up
here. The full package you get smashed,
you standing up,
he submit you on the ground ground
and pound the fuck out of you.
He could do everything. And he was just
terrifying cause it looks like a robot.
I know. There's no, no
expression, no emotion.
I was with Jeff Munson when Jeff months
and fought him in Russia and when Jeff
was walking out, it looked like a man
walking to his death. I swear to God.
And then when they fought,
it was the worst beaten I've ever
seen a human being take. Yeah.
Monson took some beatings to man
and he was getting kicked in.
Like he broke his femur. He was from
getting from lakes. Really? Yeah.
He was getting kicked in the leg so bad
and just fallen down and oh, it was,
it was a scary night.
I've felt so bad for,
Munson is Monson in Russia now,
doesn't he speak Russian and he wants
to be communist does, right? He does.
Um, I'm not sure if that's
the term he would use, but
he's socialists, socialists,
Marxists, whatever he wants to call
himself. But he's in between like Russia,
England,
and south Florida bounces around
and every so often I'm like,
yeah,
I got a weird fight and I'm fighting
in Russia or I'm fighting in Africa.
Or like these weird places where
they're fighting or he liked,
just had like a wrestling
match against like Tim Silvia,
he's doing like all this weird stuff
that no other human being does do.
When he was at the top of the,
the grappling world,
he was like wrestling a building.
Yeah. It was like wrestling a building.
He was so jacked, so jacked,
and he was so good. Yeah.
What he did. But he has a diverse
skillset, but he was sick.
He'd beat everybody to, to nothing.
Yeah. You know when he did,
he also was one of the first guys
to use the north south choke,
but he was so strong.
Like I talked to some Brazilian Jujitsu
guys and I was like, is that legit?
He's like, I think he just gooned
them grab a snack and gooned them.
But then Marcella Garcia started hitting
people with that and then everybody's
like, okay, wait a minute. What's
going on here? What is this guy doing?
And then you realize like, oh you
can, you can get it in the right way,
right? You can north south choke
a real black belt. You can,
Monson was one of the first guys to
show that, but he's so big and strong.
He was just, yeah, he would
just like just squeeze it.
What is sweaty armpit but me,
right. Marcella Garcia. In fact,
Marcella Garcia taught me how he did it
and how he does it and he showed me like
the finer details of it and I was actually
working with honey Yahya yesterday.
That kind of gets squeezed them
that and I got can squeeze,
that guy's got to squeeze and he was
doing it to me yesterday too. I was like,
you've got this. He's weird too
because you look at his body like,
how is that guy a grappler? He doesn't
like if you look at Monson you're like,
oh that guy was here.
Grab our honey. Yah, Yah.
It looks like a like a kid
who plays soccer. Not even,
he looks like he's never done
anything athletic in his life.
Like he's like really?
Yeah, he's like flimsy.
Just gets a hold of grappling ability.
His,
the way he moves and I think he's a
black belt on her Hixon. Is He really?
If he's either is either a black belt
on her Hickson or just most certainly
coached by Hixon cause I remember Hickson
was with him and some of those early
fights. Ah, he worked with Hickson's.
There was some sort of connection
between him and Hixon, but his, uh,
his, his strangles in
particular, unbelievable.
So seeing him, I've seen him tap out a
lot of good guys in the gym. I believe it.
A lot of good guys and it's like
they're just different. It just,
you know what it is. It's not that
they're different. They do it right. Yeah.
You know they do it right. They develop
a skill like whatever it is. You know,
some guys just have a triangle is
stay the fuck out of his guard.
The guy just has a triangle
that you just can't get it.
There's certain guys who just get really
proficient at one particular maneuver.
Yeah. And honey, I was like,
cause just chokes were just nasty.
So I'm working with them now on some
some ground and pound stuff to try to
incorporate that and see in south
Florida as well as cell phone. Wow.
South Florida. Goddamn hotbed. Now what
do you think about altitude training?
I mean obviously it has to work,
right? Yeah. I mean I tried it.
I don't think it worked for me. Maybe I
just didn't believe in it at the time.
But it has to work because I mean,
I dunno, maybe everybody does it.
So it has to work. It seemed like
it would work scientifically. Right.
Increases red blood cells
should work, it should definitely
increase your endurance.
But TJ Dillashaw disagrees really,
and he's got an incredible endurance and
he know he works with that Kalvia guy.
And what was their take is that your
ability to work is compromised when you
perform and train it out to it.
So even though your body
produces more red blood cells,
you don't, you're not working
as hard because you just can't,
there's not enough air. So
the idea is, I've heard the,
you should train at sea level but
then sleep at high altitude and Tj,
I believe Tj said that that's not even,
they don't even think
that's the case anymore.
I think you better off
just with all that air,
just for recuperation and
just higher work output,
higher work output and heart rate
monitoring and making sure that, you know,
you're doing like,
like Tabata intervals,
things like that where you recover and
making sure that all that's monitored,
that it's done scientifically.
Yeah. I don't know, man.
It's hard to go as hard to go against
Tj because I've never even seen him
breathe harder to fight.
So incredible. Yeah.
So like it's hard to go
against what he's saying. Um,
but I kind of liked the idea of that,
you know, I mean, I just, you know,
I'm kind of an old school guy so I don't
really believe in all the bells and
whistles and gadgets. And I guess
when Tj San is just work harder.
Yeah. Well he, he does
a lot of calisthenics,
a lot of explosive stuff,
a lot of like plyometrics.
And you ever see the shit that he
does down the, in the garage? No,
the guy's names Colivida right
Sam. Yeah. And he's apparently,
I've never worked with a
guy or even talk to him,
but massive respect from so many
different fighters to train with him.
Aaron Picos down there with,
yeah.
And this guy's just a master of
strength and conditioning looks.
They're doing a bunch of
this kind of Shit Jumpin uh,
over over a strings and Bob and
weave and under him. And I mean,
and Kalvia is like, got them all wearing
a heart rate, monitors this, this,
there's no guesswork to the training.
The training is all really well thought
out and it's all like mostly that kind
of stuff. Plow metrics, box jumps,
medicine ball work, that kind of shit.
And you know,
I mean you can't deny that
t J's in phenomenal shape
and that kind of never gets
fat. Never takes time off. Isn't just in
Colorado? No, it's here now. Oh it's hair.
Yeah they're doing, they have a new gym,
they call it the training lab but the,
the word train is,
has the word reign in it.
Like Mark Munoz style like
rain gym. So t, r, e. I n.
Yeah and they put together a gym and so
he's down here now and Dwayne goes back
and forth from Colorado to here.
Dwayne still as a school in Colorado
and he comes back here to train TJ.
So by who does Tj do work with as
far as skill wise while these hair,
the Munoz and him are doing wrestling,
he's got a bunch of people down
there and punched the Jujitsu people.
And then also like I said, Aaron Peko
is down there. It was very high level.
Bunch of a bunch of different
guys training them and I'm
really interested in to
see how he does at one 25 how his body
does with that massive weight cut.
I mean, and this is the one
thing I like about t j is it?
I don't think he's doing it just because
he feels like he's going to be better
at one 25 things and then he's doing
it because it's a challenge. Yeah.
Because he's also said he's willing to
go up to one 45 to fight Max Holloway.
So I'm kind of rooting for him.
I'd love to see Haley performs at one 25,
you know? Um, he says he can
make it. No problem. Wow,
that'd be interesting. We so
lean. You look at him now.
He's leaner than he's ever looked before.
I mean shredded now.
He looks like he's ready to weigh in now.
You know what I'm saying? Like, you know,
guys look so lean when they're weighing
in and then they fill up a little bit
when they add water. He looks
like that now. Yeah. I mean,
whether or not he's got two
little body fat, I mean,
is there a point of diminishing
returns? You know what, that's,
that's a big question and that's
the way I always see it too.
Whenever guys cut too much weight, the
returns aren't the same. Like you just,
you're depleting yourself towards almost
like the same concept is that if you
are so concerned about your weight,
your output as far as like
skilled training and physical
training isn't the same.
Look at them. They're
shredded. That's yesterday
shredded. Well, look at that.
That's ridiculous. Is He,
is he working with some on his
weight cut or is it just a,
I think Kalvia works with them on
that as well. It works with them.
With the nutrition. I mean that guy is
supposed to be a real mad scientist.
I need to talk to that gentleman and
have been here. But he's um, you know,
this is in the garage to get any
videos them training together.
Yeah. So He's nutritional analysis. Oh,
this is what he has set up for it. Oh,
he's got an APP. Jesus. Jesus. Yeah.
Become a fat burning machine. Ooh,
I want to be a fat burning machine.
Virtual training.
Yeah.
I'm interested to see how he performs
against a Soho because Soho has a hard
time making that weight as well.
Yeah.
I could imagine that he made him fight
at one 35 for a bit because he kept
missing weight. I mean, I've
seen the sides of his head.
It's a big ball on a Tito.
Yeah. It's got to Tito head, big head.
So it takes a good one. Yeah. You know,
it was big headed, but he's, you
know, for, um, for a wrestler man,
like he could box. Yeah. Well
the, uh, Wilson Hayes fine.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
Any fuck karate style on that,
when you could wrestle that good.
You can afford to be in any stats you want
because you can always just, you know,
adjust and revert back to your restaurant
position. But yeah, that's true. Yeah.
But I'm, that's interesting fight
I'm looking for, so that's next week.
I can't wait til that man. I'm on. That
is next week. It's the 19th, right? Yeah.
Are you going out to that? No, that's
Brooklyn. Yeah, that's a ESPN card.
I'm not doing that one. I only do North
American paper view now. That's it.
Ah,
big timing. Too busy. Too busy.
Too busy. Yeah. Shows on the road.
I traveled too much as it is and you know,
I don't wanna I don't want to do that.
I'm not, I don't want to go on Australia
and shit anymore. I love Australia,
but yeah, but you know that fucking,
that wrecks you for two weeks. Yeah.
I feel you. Yeah. No, I know you got,
I know you'd be, I saw you do, um,
stand up in Boston. Yeah. I'm just
open for shop. Yeah, it was fun.
Yeah, that was fun. I was proud
of him, man. Shots killing it.
He's about to do a special, that's
why, where I'm going to be on the 19th,
I'm going to be with him. He's recording
a showtime special done San Diego. Yeah.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like Dan this cause he was like,
it only done comedy for like a
year or something. Two years now.
Two years over two years. And I saw him
like, it was like a year ago. Maybe not.
Yeah,
maybe a year ago.
And he was like doing comedy for a year
and he had an hour show and it's good.
Yeah. And it was good. Yeah.
And I'm thinking like, you know,
I've dabbled in it for a couple of years
and I got five minutes. Not even I got,
I got a week five.
He's out there doing it every night.
Then you gotta do it every night.
I mean,
he's performing with me tonight at
the Improv. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got to do it every night. It's
like, it's, it's sort of like,
like you can't be good at Jujitsu if
you don't have insurance from rolling.
Right. You've got a role, you've
got to do comedy all the time.
You got to get in that mind zone. There's
like a US hypnosis, a zone of standup.
Yeah. That same thing Jim Norton told me.
Yeah. But I mean, my whole thing was like,
I'm not really in love with stand up like
that to go out and want to do it every
night. You gotta love it, grind you and
shit like you bombed the diamond bar.
You know what that feels
like? Yeah. I was like, damn,
that shit work one time. One
time, not as shit, don't work.
We'll shop.
Treats it like a professional athlete
and this is one of the things I say to
young comedians when they say,
how's he doing so good so quick,
I won't listen to me. You Lazy. Fuck.
You don't even write. You barely perform.
You do leave the same five minutes over
and over again night after night without
any improvements.
I go,
this guy is treating it like a
professional athlete would treat it.
That's the difference is having being
a funny guy already. He's funny.
Having a good mind and
then having discipline,
just discipline where you analyze your
shit and you work on it and you get
better. It's possible. He's on an
accelerated program. The most accelerated.
I never heard of anybody doing a
our special two years in. Yeah,
that's why I was like, damn, he's
killing it. Killing it. Yeah.
At least he's cool too, man. Like he
responds to my texts and shit like that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you know some,
some people you know they'd get all high
big time, big time. He's a great guy.
He like a genuine good person.
Yeah,
you look forward to seeing him succeed
and I like this is like you said,
it was funny but it was honest.
You know what he's talking about his
career and his life is honest and like a
lot of people aren't willing
to be that vulnerable.
They want to be the cool guy. Yay.
Always trying to be too to cool.
The cool guy has not funny.
It's not funny to be the cool guy so
that's why like, yes.
Why? Because that lay man,
every batch has to be the cool guy and
he'd get out and get away with that.
All the actors try to be the cool guy or
rappers may be actors and maybe singers
and musicians. Maybe they tried to be
the cool guy but then comedian world,
there's no room for that. You know,
people paid money to hear you talk about,
I have some funny shit to say.
If you have some funny shit to say,
but you don't have any funny shit
to say about you. That seems weird.
It seems weird. Yeah. So you
gotta be kind of Self Katen.
Open it up, open up Pandora's
box. Let's see this,
those zombies. What's in
there? What are the demons?
Let them out. Let them out. You know,
you can only do so many specials before
you let the demons out and he might be
able to get away with one special
making fun of stuff outside of you.
But you gotta you have to have ever,
you have to be able to see everything.
If you're going to be a comedian,
you're going to keep going.
You could be how you're looking at the
world and if how you're looking at the
world, none of it is reflecting
on you. None of it. Yay. Yeah.
If it's reflecting on you and you're
funny, you gotta be able to be a fool.
You have to be able to be a fool.
You have to every, every great comic.
Makes fun of themselves.
Yeah. I mean, I so,
I mean I do more Improv Shit, you know,
mass air always gives me shit for that.
Cause I hang out with nerds and
fucking Improv Improv troupe.
I do more of that shit. Matt Serra, it
gives you a hard time. Oh my God. Oh,
fucking lemon improv troop.
I'm a theater nerd, man. I hang out
with a little Improv nerds and shit,
so I do that. But um, but I guess why I
didn't really dig into stand up as much.
I don't know. It was for some
reason I was just like, man,
I don't got time to be going out there
and fucking every night get my fucking
teeth kicked in buddies.
Yeah.
I know it's necessary and it's
part of the process. Yeah.
But it's not necessarily, if you
don't want to do it, like it's,
it's not something everybody
should do. Yay. You tried it,
you didn't like it. And it's not that I
don't like it neither. That's the thing.
It's like I don't mind
it. Yeah. It's just, yeah.
But I feel like if you want to be good
at it and get to the next level, right.
Did you have to fucking
go through that process?
You would say the same thing to a fighter.
If you had a fighter that was coming in,
like I like to train but I don't
have to train that much. Like don't,
you're not fighting you gotta
you gotta love this thing.
If you want to be a
professional fighter man,
do you have to have a singular focus?
Like you have to be really driven and
dedicated and the difference between that
is with comedy. Yeah, you
might get your teeth kicked in,
but with fighting you're going to get
your teeth kicked in like really good and
I'm really fucking banged up.
And you have to be able to suffer almost
every day in order to get yourself into
kind of condition that you need to
be in to fight. You need to have,
there's a level of discipline that you
need to have to be a professional fighter
that's almost unequaled in sports.
Yeah. Cause, I mean it can like that
because it's not just discipline like you,
you have to have great discipline.
If you want to be a runner and you
want to be a marathon runner or a great
discipline,
if you want to be a professional football
player or a professional basketball
player, but the difference
between fighting is you have
to have great discipline,
but you also are going to get fucked up.
You're also going to get
your face punched in.
You're gonna get your liver kicked, you
know you're gonna get a LIMS pulled. Yeah.
You going to get your legs thumped with
shins slamming into the meatier leg
where everything goes numb. Oh,
don't remind me. Thump and arm.
I don't do that shit no more.
Do your legs go back to normal,
to the point where you don't feel
like you could take it anymore.
I can't take kicks no more. Isn't that
a weird thing? Like he did develop,
I could ability to absorb those.
Like if you watch like Robert van but
reus smiling or something like that.
Robin van Moose Mile and look,
I'll take a leg kick and it's like,
it doesn't even seem to affect him, but
when you stop doing it, you can't go back.
Right. I mean do you you spa
around a little bit? No. Yeah.
No I haven't kickbox Barden forever.
I was,
I just think like getting hit in the
head should be something that you should
decide. Okay. No more of that.
Like this should be a time where like
you could spar Jujitsu and you can keep
going pretty much forever.
I mean,
Leo was sparring when he
was in his nineties he was
still rolling but striking.
It's like at a certain point in time
you got to stop. Yeah, I don't do it,
eh? Yeah. I barely, I mean honestly
I barely role to be honest with you.
Like I just study,
study,
study to gain work out a little bit.
Like,
I mean I still have to roll at times
to drive the kind of workouts. Do you
guys know that happens? A lot of fighters,
they stop fighting and they see, I mean,
he spent so many years like
running and doing all this stuff.
Like when you're done,
like the last thing you want to do is run.
If that like Tyron Woodley, we going
to camp and I said, hey listen,
you got to buy me a bike if you want me
to go alongside of you by your running.
I ain't running with joy ass.
It's gotta be hard for him to
run too. Cause he's so thick.
Yeah. Yeah. He's, I mean,
he hates running,
but like I think that part of,
part of that motivates him to go to smoke.
Fucking made me run fucking him up.
Yeah. So he, but yeah, so it's tiring now.
35 35 maybe 36 how many more years
do you think he's kind of left?
Hey, be bullshitting. He be like, yeah,
another three years. I don't think so.
You know his rap career about to take off.
So you think so? I don't know. I mean,
you know, I mean, he's such, he's
the most hustling guy I've ever met.
He's always on TMZ. He hustles. He
always doing something. The castles.
So does he have a podcast? Well, me and
him had one together, but we got one now.
Yeah. But we don't have a record
because he'd be, what is it?
What's it called? It's uh, it's the,
it's the morning wood. Oh, okay.
I've heard of that before. So, but we, we
ain't recorded in like a year. Oh, well.
So he'll really have
inconsistent consistent
to say the least. That's the
number one thing about podcasts.
You've gotta be consistent. Well,
yeah, so like I do one now with, uh,
with Tj to San has called the beat down
and like, and I'm like, dude, wait,
let's record. We've got to
record. Because like you said,
consistency is key to everything.
There's too many out there.
People get bored with you. Yeah. If you
don't, if you don't give them call like,
you gotta make them addicted.
And the only way to make them addicted
is you got to first of all be addicted.
You gotta be enjoying all these
conversations because it's the,
it's the only way that it is, um, that
it's contagious. There's no other way.
Like if you're half asking or faking it,
you really don't want
to talk to these people.
Then that comes through people's
ears. They hear that, you know,
like I always love talking
to people. I like, I'm,
I've always been like when I was in the
brief amount of time I was in college,
the only thing that interests
me with psychology. Really?
Yeah, I was interested.
I W W because I knew my own mind.
Like I got into psychology because I'm
the same reason why I got into philosophy
because I was scared, scared of fighting.
I was like, what's wrong with my brain?
Like why am I was scared like why am I,
why am I scared before every tournament
and scared before all these different
things. Like what? And then I
realize everybody's scared. Okay,
well how do people manage that? Like what?
What did, is there a right way to think?
Cause I knew that sometimes I would go
in there with a perfect mindset and I'd
win that feel great and
then I couldn't recreate it.
Like two weeks later I'm like,
well what the fuck is wrong with my head?
How do I figure this out?
So I was wanting to talk to people
and find out like what makes you tick?
Like what, what, what, what
motivates you? How do you,
how do you discipline yourself?
Like what are you thinking about
when you're pushing yourself?
Like what are you thinking
about when you're calm?
Do you spend time reflecting on your work?
Do you just keep going and keep doing
it or do you analyze it? Like what,
what is happening with you?
Like what do you do? And then,
so a podcast to me almost came
naturally because I'm always,
I'm always talking to people and
I'm always trying to do, I want to,
I was trying to like get behind the
doors of the eyes, like what's in there.
But that's said Jim Norton said
that about you too. He's like,
it's a great conversation.
Lessons. It's blinking and shit.
Well, I'm curious, I'm like, I don't
want to just talk. I want to, I want to,
I want to hear people,
like sometimes comedians are just waiting
for their turn to talk and they're not
listening to you.
Like,
I've always tried very hard to listen
to people and trying to like see what,
where they're coming from, trying to get
into their head. So let me ask you this.
Did you ever figure it out?
But, uh, why you couldn't, uh,
manage wow. Those emotions.
Yeah. I was young. First of all,
I stopped fighting when I was 21 or 22,
somewhere in that range
between 21 and 22. Um, I, um,
there was also no future.
That was a problem too.
It wasn't like I was working towards
something when I was fighting.
It was stopped in 88,
89 I think.
Maybe I had my last kickboxing
fights and there was no,
there was no future. There was no
nowhere to go. Like kickboxing,
you got like $500 for a fight.
You get your brains punched in.
There was no money in taekwondo. And then
the Olympic scoring system, the Olympics
were incredibly corrupt.
Like the scoring was terrible,
especially if you fought
a Korean, Oh, good Lord.
And not window and not winning at
a beat the living fuck out of them.
In order to Orient to stop them,
had a k o them. And then, um,
I was also seeing brain
damage. I was seeing people
in the gym with brain damage,
especially when I started kickboxing
because I was spending a lot of time in
boxing gyms.
I've seen guys that were slurring and
stuttering their words and they just acted
weird. And you see guys that
acted different after a Kol,
they got KOD and then you see them
just a little bit more distant,
a little bit more glassy eyed and slack
jaw and you're like, oh Jesus Christ.
Like you see it. Yeah. I
mean, I hate it, man. It,
it breaks my heart every time I see a
guy take unnecessary punishment. Yeah.
And not even,
even if he's not slur of just like taking
unnecessary punishment as you know,
where it leads,
I know where it leads and it really
breaks my heart when I see like the fans,
like expect it from fighters. Yeah. They,
um, you know, they don't know what
they're watching. You know, they're just,
they're just watching violence that it's
almost like it's not really their, yeah.
It's not really happening. They don't,
they don't know what it's like. Yeah.
Where the guy gets knocked out. And then,
because if for them it's over, they just,
you know, they going back to
the regular life. But for me,
I'm going to the hospital with this
motherfucker got knocked out and he's got
his fucking eyes,
you know,
busted open and he's all busted up orbital
bone and, and for the next, you know,
three or four months,
you know,
this guy's depressed because he was trying
to cater to the fans and put on this
exciting fight and yet he
then went through all this
punishment and that's just
then, and then if you do
that, have a career of that,
you're going to be fucked up.
Yeah. There's no, I
don't like it. You know,
it's, uh, it's just,
it's hard when guys don't know how to
get out or where to go when they get out.
And this hard, when you see them
knowing that they have to get out,
but they're still fighting. Oh yeah.
That's the worst man. I'm always like,
damn, what do you do when you have
a fighter that you know should stop?
I'm pretty honest with them. I'm always
honest. I'm always like, man, listen,
this ain't for you no more.
And I always have to tell them like if I,
if I feel like it's going to affect
them physically and hurt them,
but by continuing to fight, I
tell them, hey, you need to stop.
And more often than not,
they kind of listened.
They probably kind of know where they
kind of know and they just needed somebody
else to say it. And I'm more willing to
tell them. I always try to tell them,
but sometimes if they don't want to do it,
then I can't really be a part of it.
Like when you saw Tito versus
chuck? Yeah, that's one of the,
my opinion.
And no disrespect to chuck,
he should do whatever he
wants to do. Maybe he enjoys
it, maybe wants to compete.
But that was one of the worst examples
of a guy who used to be a fuck and a
stroller. Chuck was a district. Hello?
Oh man, dude. Randleman CalEd Randleman
failed everybody. He was
out. He was a killer.
Chuck was a straight up
killer and watching him fight
fucking Palae Landy bare
knuckle in Brazil. Yeah. When
they had the net and the ropes,
he had knocked down with three times with
head kicks and still pay Paleo. Yeah,
man, that's, yeah. And then the
watch him and then again another,
another cases scenario where like young
fighters see him and go on his old guy.
Yeah. But he shouldn't be fighting. Yeah.
You shouldn't be fine at 50 and he
clearly can't take a punch anymore.
She like whatever it is.
Like when Tito connected on him,
everything just shut off.
Yeah. You see it just shut off.
And then Tito smashes him
and we tell him about Tito.
We're not exactly talking about
fucking Anthony Johnson. That's true.
But I think Tito's punches are a lot
better than they used to be. Yeah.
And I think Perillo Jason Parillo is a
fantastic coach and I think he did an
amazing job. And I think Tito, you
know, he's just not a natural Stryker.
It's not like his thing. He's
a wrestler, but it's the way,
the way it happened. It
just, chuck couldn't connect.
He is like everything
looked off his timing,
his movement, he just looked,
is balanced, looked off.
And when you talk to people that are
neuroscientists and they understand what
happens to the brain after repeated brain
trauma over and over and over again,
and then what we're seeing
is just in the cage.
We don't have no idea how much brain
trauma he took in camps and it's probably
pretty magnificant. Yeah, I
would assume his style was so,
he's such a brawler and he had an iron
chin for the beginning of his career.
It was, it just one of the greatest
chins of all time. So when it failed him,
there was no, there was no escape
clause. There was no, there was no way.
There was no back door. This
was the style. The style wasn't.
All of a sudden you're going to be like
mighty mouse and not get hit and switch
stances and become slick.
That shit is just not available.
And when you saw him with
this hampered movement,
he just doesn't,
is balanced doesn't seem right.
Like I was watching him hit the
pads when they were preparing,
when he's getting ready, I was
watching hit the pass. I was like,
what is happening here?
Because balance looks fucked up.
Like it didn't look right.
Like even when he's throwing kicks he
like threw a kick and then fall back like
it didn't look right. We have what I
mean. And I feel that even with myself,
like I don't have the same
balance I had when I was 20 right.
And I could imagine him
like, cause he probably never
even focused on that. Right.
He just did it. He just, he
was just throwing punches.
So for him that like I watch a video of
him shadow boxing, horrendous, rough,
horrendous. But then you go back
and watch him when he was the champ.
It's like Jesus Christ. Hey, harder. No,
I watched him hit the bag and he's
like a fucking murderer. He had speech,
our power,
everything,
putting it together and just
that style. Just a, I mean,
the reason why he became
such a fan favorite,
you knew chuck Liddell was
coming to kill you. I mean,
he was coming to kill you and that cage
door shut and they said, let's get it on.
He just stepped forward and just looking
at smash. And that was his style.
And it was the reason why
the UFC became so famous.
One of the big reasons why the UFC
became so popular with chocolate Dell,
he was a guy who everybody
could identify with. Yeah.
And the fan base at a UFC saw
themselves in chuck Liddell will,
they wished the wished
that could be that guy
to save had the Mohawk.
The Tattoo was fearless,
was knocking people out and
it scream afterwards. Yeah.
It's like they saw what they saw it.
I said, I won't be that guy. Yeah.
And you're right. And that's how the UFC
became so popular so fast. As with Joe,
when you see him now at 50 fighting
the way fought against Tito,
you're like so hard to watch.
But then the other hand it's like,
I don't want to tell the guy what to do.
He's not going to live forever.
Like if this is what he really enjoys
and he wants to do that, I mean,
and maybe it wouldn't be the worst idea
in the world for him to keep going.
I don't know. I don't know. I'm
not, his dad got him, you know,
I don't know what to tell
him. I mean, it also,
you got to think like he
probably does worst thing.
He's in his life and
then getting in the cage with an old
buddy. You know? You think so probably.
I mean, I never hung out with the dude,
but I'm just saying you heard stories?
Yeah.
Yeah. Well you does.
Hanging out at the church.
He definitely did his share of partying.
Yeah. Which doesn't help. Yeah. Yeah.
Depending upon what your
partying with too, you know,
I'm sure there's certain substances that
are worse than others when it comes to
your brain.
See,
that's why I can't ever live in La.
I'm staying my ass in Florida.
Well, what's in Florida?
It's the cocaine capital of the world. I
know, man, but I'm not as much access. He,
yeah.
I don't know.
The party scene just seems it's not
the same as Florida fucking Florida,
if not of Miami's got to have the craziest
party scene on the planet and you can
stay away from that though.
Yeah. Well you can because of the gym
and hanging around with the right people,
but whenever I'm down in Miami, I'm like,
this is the most chaotic place ever.
Yeah. Miami, like I never go to Miami.
I don't ever go down there. Really?
Yeah, it's fun place. Last time
I did a gig there though, I was,
it was right before I was
filming my Netflix special,
and so we have these yonder bags. Yonder
is a cell phone bag that they use. Well,
you have to put yourself
on this magnetically sealed
bag to get into the room
and the only way to use your phone
as you got to leave the room,
they opened the bag for you.
They give you your phone,
you hold onto your phone the whole time.
You have possession of it,
but it's sealed in this bad key people
from texting and filming and all that
kind of shit while the show's
going on every other place.
It accentuated the show because it made,
it made the show like 10% better
because people were just focused.
They weren't staring at their phone.
They're just focused at the show in Miami,
all people kept doing is just getting up
to go outside, do use their
phone. It was like the, no,
it sat down on the wholesale then
pop it up and move and pop up.
Just made it worse.
It made it worse.
Put like when Tiffany Haddish,
she just bombed in Miami.
It was like this big TMZ deal that
she bombed there. I'm like, yeah,
in Miami you got to grab those
motherfuckers. You got to go, hey,
here's the show.
What I did,
I tell you know,
south Florida is probably the
most unfocused place on earth.
Like nobody's focused on
anything. Nothing. I said, if
you want to starve to death,
open a bookstore in Miami.
Yeah, that's true, man.
People Miami, like they
don't, they don't have no,
they don't have no football team.
They got the dolphins,
but Dane Tam dealt Miami Dolphins.
They pay, they'll pay attention,
pay attention to the Florida Marlins.
Nothing but having fun and partying and
that's all they want to do. Fuck. Yup.
That's all they do. Like on South
Beach. It's great for that. Yeah.
That's your sport.
Yeah.
But for him to dancing and
fucking Miami is the place to be.
They got great food in Miami.
Great food, great food. Yeah.
Fantastic. Cuban buddy. Yeah. Cuba
food. Yeah. Yeah, you're right.
There's some great restaurants in Miami.
Bunch of great restaurants.
Yeah. I mean it's a great spot.
It's just not the best spot for everything
other than it's not best buy for anything
other than partying and fucking party
to fucking and apparently
and eating Cuban food.
You ever watched those documentaries on
uh, on a cocaine, the cocaine
cowboys document I've seen.
Oh, Dan, you're going to be so happy.
You got to watch these
cocaine cowboys one and two.
There are some of the greatest
fucking document and you,
you're going to realize why
Miami is so fucking bananas.
The amount of cocaine
that went through Miami,
they said that at one point in time,
I don't know if that's still the case,
but at one point time Miami had more
banks per capita than anywhere else in the
continent and it's all because the
cocaine money was being laundered through
Miami. These areas, 100% there was,
this is all Billy Corbin's documentary.
He's got two documentaries, fantastic
documentaries, cocaine cowboys wanting to,
but one of the things that it talked
about is one year every single member of
the graduating class of the police academy
either was murdered or went to jail
every single member. Dot. Entire
Police Academy. It was corrupt.
They were all deeply involved in the
drug game. Yeah, yeah. It was chaos.
It was chaos.
It was just people were making
millions of dollars in burring holes,
be putting bags of it in their backyard,
just digging holes in the backyard
and drop in fucking big ole sack,
some money in there. Are you sick
garbage bags filled with cash? Yeah,
probably still out there,
but probably guys died and there's garbage
bags filled with cash that they left
in their backyard. They forgot
about it because they got
shot. Oh yeah, it's there.
Great documentaries, but
I need to find out. Right.
They lived.
I'm going digging shovel by some sketchy
looking at houses and start digging in
the backyard. Oh my God. I didn't
know it was that crazy. So crazy.
I didn't know it was that
crazy. He's until I watched
all the documentaries. It's,
there's so good. Probably if I had a top
10 list of documentaries of all time,
cocaine cowboys is on
there. That good. No Shit.
100% must watch. Yeah. Especially
if it's on Netflix. Right?
I'm sure you don't dent flicks.
Cocaine cowboys. Certainly on iTunes.
It's so good. You just go, oh
my God. It's like you shut up.
You don't know about Grizelda. Who says
held a Blanco? She's this pitch that was,
she was running everything back then.
It was a woman and a woman,
evil woman that was running everything.
Murderer.
Just a straight killer hired all
these savages. Just gun people down.
Babies, women, children,
everybody dead. Dead.
Ruthless. Yeah. So what happened to
her? She still, she's dead. She went,
she went to a jail in Columbia and uh,
she got out.
They let her out. There was pictures of
her with her girlfriend. She was like,
sometimes she was a lesbian,
sometimes she wasn't.
But there was a pictures of her with
her girlfriend and Bogota after she got
released.
Like that lady is responsible
for the death of who knows
how many fucking people,
millions of dollars moved
around in money. Yeah. Yeah man,
it's a fucking Dick. Great documentaries.
Great Shit. Can't recommend them enough.
Oh yeah. I got to see this. You
got to see it. Yeah. You're gonna,
you're gonna text me afterwards even
go, oh shit. I had no idea that, I mean,
I knew Miami was bad. I mean obviously I
get so close to, you know, South America,
so I'm sure that's Kinda gotta be a hub.
But I didn't know it was like Jennifer
Lopez is playing her in a movie,
isn't she? Did that movie came out? No,
it was like it might,
it didn't.
Maybe they didn't make it really or
maybe not yet. She's too hot. Who?
Jennifer Lopez to play this girl.
This girl wasn't costing. Oh really?
Well how is she going to get
some Joey Diaz with a wig on?
She was evil man.
Super Evil.
It's just interesting with a whole crime
syndicate run by a woman, you know,
cause you like see that in the movie
in a movie. The fuck out of here? No,
this is happening for real cause all the
Blanco. Yeah. Damn put on power though.
She killed everybody at 2016
she was labeled with it.
But then 2017 there's article saying
that Catherine Zeta Jones and her work
competing for it. Oh, but it's an HBO
TV movie that has yet to be made. So
pull up a picture of her.
The real Griselda Blanco.
I'm telling you too much. You need
to watch it. Just need to watch it.
There she is right there. Joey Diaz.
What are were gone. Yeah, it is.
See how has the,
that's how I would make up.
Imagine where she looks like in the
morning. We're just taking a shit. Yeah.
That was her boyfriend.
Yeah.
He got in trouble because he was
banging some chicks while she was, uh,
in the pokey. Can you
blame him? Nope. Nope.
Look at her evil damn evil evil.
They talked to her hit man.
Her hitman gets interviewed in the
movie from jail and like, you know,
talk about like what the
rules were and how she,
how she ran things.
The amount of money that those people
made is just ungodly sums of money and
nobody knew how to get out. It was like
once that money's flowing and you know,
you're making $30 million a week
or whatever the fuck you're making.
Like when do you get out? When, when
you get out, how do you get out? Yeah.
You can't get out of that. And if you
do get out, like who takes over? Yeah.
Who takes over the distribution and then
everybody I think probably just says,
AH, next year. Yeah, next year.
This is my last year doing this.
Then the match to catch bullets. The only
way out is death. Yeah. I have a friend,
a very good friend. My friend
Steve Graham, who did his right,
he's an ophthalmologist.
He did his residency in Miami and was
doing his residency in the emergency room
in Miami while the cocaine
days were going on.
He said every day just blown up.
Heads, bullet holes, cocaine,
the godmother review stuff.
They made it brown face casting.
It's just one of many insults. And this
Schlocky Narchos rip off. What? Oh,
that is brown face.
Look at that.
That lady's supposed to be
resolved to block out Zeta Jones.
That's not Catherine Zeta.
Yeah. Jones is it? Yeah,
but it doesn't look like
her at all. Does it? Yeah,
but it doesn't look like the lady at
all. A wall. You didn't even get fat. No,
you didn't even get fat. Come on man.
That's the difference between her and uh,
the uh, what's her face from,
um, who was in monster? Oh,
I'm honest. My Curl. Charlies.
Charlies. They're on. Yeah, she got fat.
She did it the right way. She played
that lady the right way. Rector,
body code called cocaine godmother.
Eh, that was a lifetime movie.
She needed to give it a day.
How'd you not give it an f?
Anything you want to lifetime.
Is it a d or f at least, but I think
Catherine Zeta Jones is Latina,
so that's kind of fucked up that they
said they whitewashed or cause isn't that
Shane is in Catherine Zeta Jones
from Columbia. I said that.
I don't know. She's also apparently
losing her marbles. Really? Yeah.
I read that. So you asked the, I don't
know about this Hollywood shit, man.
It just scares me to get out of
here outside. I noticed that.
I'm like, man, you, this is often the cut
a little bit. So she's Welsh, Welsh. Oh,
sorry. Oh, sorry. Sorry. From the
United Kingdom. My, my apologies. Yeah,
they whitewash the shit
out of it. Yeah. Yeah.
How could you not give that
role to a fat Mexican lady?
How could you not Colombian
lady can find a fat lady. Yeah.
Why not? I'm working anyway. He, here's
what you do. You have some stars.
You put them in supporting positions.
Yeah. And have her played a role. Yeah.
I mean, go to Telemundo at channel.
They got many of them on there.
Kevin's into John's was Welsh.
That don't even make no sense.
I thought she was like Latino Columbia.
She was so hot when she was young.
She's still married to old boy. What's
his name? Mike Douglas. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Look at that out.
She come on and tell me she doesn't look
like Colombian or something. Which does,
right? Yeah. Well what
are you gonna do? Yeah.
Whitewash. Yeah. That's Kinda
crazy. You can't do that anymore.
That's cultural appropriation, son.
What's wrong with that kid? Do it. Yeah.
You can't do it right now. Well, listen,
anything that offends people may need
stay away from it just because it's too
much work. Yeah, that's the, yeah.
It's just too much work. It is.
It's just too much work. I sl, I
feel about the talent. You can say
it's like talking to people about
politics. Like, yeah, I'm done.
I'm not talking about this
interested and I don't,
and I'm not in a position to tell
anybody. We can offend them in, you know,
Snow Flake. I'm not in, I'm not going
to do it. I ain't call nobody snowflake.
Listen,
something's going to offend somebody,
but it's just too much work and
it's too much work. This too.
Especially for someone like
you. You're busy. Yeah.
I ain't got time for this shit shit to do.
You don't want to be arguing with
people all day on Twitter. Oh,
about foreign policy.
Oh Man.
I try. I try to stay off of Twitter banner
and sometimes I'll be in the middle of
writing a tweet and I go, I ain't, you
know, sending this shit good for you man.
Good for you. I'm more friends. And that
Bert Kreischer just deleted his shit.
He deleted his shit off his phone. He
go, he, yeah, he deleted the APP. Yeah.
Twitter, Twitter at. Yeah. I don't
know why people are doing that now.
I know a lot of people are deleting
Twitter and they just don't,
they don't read it anymore.
Don't pay attention to it anymore.
I go in every now and then,
but I, the way I describe it,
it's always like peering into a
haunted house. Like, Whoa, yeah.
Fuck's going on in there.
Well,
the problem is that it puts
everybody on the same level.
So like you'd have shit,
you know what I'm saying?
You work your hardest to get something
and then you let these fucking guys just
sign in and talk shit to you, you
know? Right. They don't do nothing.
They'll do nothing in life but get on,
sign their name in and just talk shit.
There's a lot of that.
And sometimes someone would talk shit
to me and I'm like, who's this guy?
I'm like, what is going on with this
guy's life? And then I'll, I don't,
I don't get upset, but I will click
their profile and then I look, oh,
they just talk shit to celebrities.
Yeah, that's what they do.
They talk shit to Nas and Jay and fucking,
you know,
but it's hard sometimes
you just like, I see a,
what's the name and your boy Chris
Delea, right? Yeah. Crystal Lee.
And like he'd be on that. Most of
people. Shit. Yeah, he loves it.
But his board is that what it is? Doesn't
do anything. This is what Chris does.
Writes Jokes, goes to gym,
Talk Shit Online all day.
He's like making little funny videos.
And like he just can't wait
to do stand up his wishes.
Comedy clubs were operating
at noon. Really? Yeah. To
Leah loves doing stand up.
If comedy clubs were open at noon,
he had the store like almost
every night of the week.
He just can't wait to stand up again.
Can't wait to go up there and kill
just the most fun. Really? Yeah.
So when he's not doing that,
he's talking shit.
The Logan Paul and fucking this guy
and that guy anyway. And He's good too.
So anyway, he says he'll crush
you. Crush it. I watched him,
I watched him embarrassed Logan. Paul
felt so. I feel bad for Logan Paul,
but I would just like, you'll hurt
your feelings. Yeah, it will hurt.
You feel so good at that.
But I'm thinking like, man,
don't you got anything else to do? He
doesn't do off the day. He doesn't,
he doesn't read.
He's not doing anything.
He's not interested in like bettering
himself at all. It's doesn't care of me.
That's just who he is. He just likes being
funny and he likes talking Shit. Like,
if you look at his videos,
like he puts videos up on Instagram.
They're just funny. This is
him, Dan. Fucking ridiculous
and being silly. I mean,
it's, you got going on
here. What's he doing here?
Talking Shit about the Coachella. That's
very short. Okay, we hear this again.
The people and the bands played
Coachella this year are fuck.
So sorry.
Three to the lobby were just like,
this is the perfect way to it is,
is it that bad? What is going
on with Coachella? Was it bad?
Sure. I don't know. Sure. What are
the names? I mean it's just hold,
I got the arguments people were making.
It's just that I can Instagram concert.
People are just going to have pictures
up. There's always a lot of that, right?
Oh,
also someone that Coachella lineup?
No,
not that one.
What do we got here? Hmm? Who Do we got?
Childish Gambino can't go wrong
there. Um, who are these other people?
I don't know who these people are.
Kid Cuddy.
Weezer I'm trying to see
people that I recognize.
Uh, Ariana Grande Day. What?
I'd be really mad if I was a DJ Khalid
and I saw Ariana Grande's names so much
bigger than mine. Oh, that's color. That's
a different, that's a different one.
He's a singer. How are you,
how do you have the same names?
The other guy because the other
one was a DJ Cuban Dj. Ah,
get on what yourself. Who
is Boy Paulo? Pablo boy,
Pablo,
way down there.
Tiny little name and then this dude
smaller name than him whose razor bumps.
I think that's part of what he is.
Maybe laughing at razor bumps is a,
that's what you get when you shave your
pussy. Nope. Don't make that as a name.
That's ridiculous.
There's US girls and then I trust are
both also there. Um, social house. Okay.
No disrespect to any of these bands.
I'm sure they're really good. But yeah,
Chris is right along super organism.
Oh super. Organisms are that. They're
working again. What serpent with feet.
Okay. Shut this up. Before
I become crystal Leah
music today, man, everybody had
to come out with music these days.
A lot of musicians. I'm not in that
business. I don't understand it.
I have them on here. I don't
know how they do it. I'm like,
I don't know what you're doing,
but you have him on here all the time.
Musician musicians all the
time. But I'm like, I just,
that world is just such a difficult,
it's so difficult to break through.
Like it seems like the most difficult
world to break through because of the
competition. Does everybody thinks they
can do it. There's a lot of competition,
especially rappers.
You don't have to hold a note.
All you have to do is just make Shit Ryan.
Yeah.
And you don't even really have to do that.
Not Anymore. Now I can mumble your way.
Things. Yeah, you're right.
Like the rap industry got like,
at least in fighting,
you can win. You keep going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And fighting.
You just fuck people up.
Yeah. And if you fuck everybody up, you
win. Yeah. You win and you're going to be,
you're going to be the greatest ever.
Nobody has to like you once
they lock that cage door show,
you just fucked that person up.
I'm sorry I didn't like it,
but I fucked your boy up. Cut
and dry. That's what it is.
And rap or music
industry. It's like, yeah,
I'm the best I can. There's a lot of
biting, a lot of stealing, stealing wraps,
and stealing rhymes and does a
lot of that in that world too.
It's rough and comedy.
If people are laughing and then
you keep going in that, I suppose.
Yeah, but also in comedy,
there's so many places to work.
Like the, so many comedy clubs. There's
so many comedy clubs. Oh really?
So you can work a lot. As a
comedian, you can work every night.
You might not get booked as a beginner,
but once you get going at once,
like you name a guy who's, who's a good
colleague, Adam Hunter. Perfect example.
Good comments. Like how it works
everywhere. He's always working.
He's always got something going on
and you could, if he was a rapper,
he would be fucked. You know what I mean?
It's like if you're that level wrapper,
like there's not a lot of options for you.
Where are you going to work?
There's no rap club. I'm going to go
to the rap club. Do a five minute set.
That's shit's not real.
I you're right.
But comedy. Yeah. I, but I didn't know,
but I thought it was kind of hard to get
put on though. Like as a, it's not, well,
not for Adam obviously because
he's pretty successful,
but in the beginning there's plenty of
little tiny places and bring her shows
where you do like, you know, a couple
minutes and then once you're good comedy,
uh, one thing about comedians, they
help each other. Yeah. Really? Yeah.
I heard it was like the
opposite. What'd you hear that?
Well, Norton, no, no, no, no,
no. Wasn't Tim didn't today said,
um, it's different in New York. Yeah.
There's some comedians they
get jealous of other ones.
Did have a hat that are successful. Yeah.
Those are the ones that suck. Yeah. Okay.
That makes sense. The good ones support
other ones that are good because
you realize you need them. It's almost
like you need a, if you're in a gym,
you need guys that are really good
around here. Pushing a chain of potters.
You need that with comedy too. Yeah. You
need other comedians who are really good,
elevates your, your idea of what's
good. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah.
I think in general comedians are probably
one of the more supportive of all art
forms, one of the more supportive
of other people that are doing it.
I would hope so because it's such a,
a world where if as I should be comedian
against the audience it seems like,
so like you kind of need people to,
to support you and have your back
and go and I'll worry about that one.
As long as Nolan stealing from you
when they're on stage, you're not.
So it shouldn't affect you at all.
And in fact you probably got into
comedy because you're a fan of comedy.
That's how I got into it.
So if I was,
if I didn't enjoy other people
that were really good at it,
like what I took away,
the one thing that I really love to
watch and then I started doing it for a
living, now I can enjoy it anymore. That's
crazy. Knowing what you enjoy it is.
You got to appreciate
something that's really good.
You can't be seeing someone
go on that good. Yeah.
It could be better shows
up to fuck that crowd.
So do you still go watch sometimes,
like you watch your homeboys? Yes. Yes.
To Watch my friends.
Yeah, all the time. Yeah.
That's one of the reasons
why if I go on the road,
I always bring really funny
people with me. I'm on a laugh.
I want to laugh before I go up.
Some comedians don't want that though.
They want the audience to be suffering
until they get up the terrible opening
acts. What? Yeah, like a
terrible idea. I agree.
But see you're coming at it
from a martial arts perspective,
like martial artists, like
look, you martial artists,
first of all, everybody supports
everybody. Everybody helps everybody.
You have to training together. You're
working with, there's coaching,
there's like you're, you're,
you're advancing each other
that you appreciate it.
When someone fuck somebody up. Like you
realize like damn the guy is good. That's,
this is good. This is like a lot of props.
Like, if you see like a comedy special,
you'll see a bunch of comedians tweeting
about how good a comedy special is.
You don't,
I don't think you see that much in the
rap world or someone is really good.
And then a bunch of other people,
other rappers or chime in about how great
that thing was. You won't see. Yeah,
you're right. That's, you're right
about that. But with the finders,
you do have some money. Fuck somebody
up and like some, some big like, damn.
He looked good tonight. They look
good and you'll see all this chatter.
All the people supporting it. Yeah. Rap
is the opposite. The opposite. Yeah.
Fuck everybody. Fuck, fuck, fuck the
tro games. That's the weird
one, right? That drug game.
Oh Man. Do you, uh, do you
anticipate staying in south Florida?
I don't know. I mean, so I
don't know if they have it on.
Where are you from originally
from Delaware? Yeah. So I
got buddies from Delaware.
I know. I'm the only one. I made it
to the only person ever escape it.
Actually me and I'm, remember
it was a state, you know,
here's an interesting fact.
Me and Roxanne and modifier
was born in the same. Really?
Yeah. Wow. That's crazy. Yeah.
What are the odds? I don't
know. I know, but I'm not,
I'm originally from Delaware,
so eventually I feel like
I want to be a snowbird.
Yeah. Meaning, you know, yeah. So coat
hang out in Florida during the, um,
during the winter months. Yeah. And
where were you live? And the other time,
I don't know. I might go
Pennsylvania, Jersey or some shit.
That's a vein like Philly. Yeah. That's
a math. My focus is wrong. Really.
Phil is nice. Yeah. I love
Philly. Philly's real, you
know what it was like? Yeah.
I said they're really intelligent people
that will punch you in the face. Yeah.
That's Philly. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
They're wow. Wow. Yeah. They,
they're real and they're
passionate and they're, wow. Yeah.
So you kinda have to like
that. Uh, yeah. It's, uh, in,
they're better looking than
Boston. Sorry, Boston really?
Girls are better looking at Philly. Why
is that? I don't know. It's too smart.
And if I grew up in Boston. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't know about that. I think,
um,
Boston is dealing with a lot of the
original genes of the original travelers
didn't made it across that boat.
Just savage folk that didn't want
to live in Europe anymore. Yeah.
Those genes are not the best jeans.
Bunch of animals.
They're still dealing with them.
Fucking jeans still punching each other
and a lot of fist fights in Boston. Yeah.
You go out on a Friday,
Saturday night and go around the bars.
You'll see plenty of
fist fights in Boston.
That's one of the few places in the
world where people still are going to
regular basis. Beat the shit out
of each other on the streets.
That's good then you know, at least
ain't shooting drunk and savages. Well,
there's some shootings too for sure. But
there's a lot of law of knuckling down.
Yeah.
It's kind of good.
But I think there's something
to that gene whole gene thing.
When I was in Milwaukee and I was like,
damn, why these fucking people so ugly.
Yeah,
it's true.
Got Those old g like I need to
get some mixing going on. Yeah.
Well I think that's the
reason why California has
some of the best look in jeans
because the people that
lived on the east coast,
like I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
They kept going until they got to
California and they hit that water might,
I don't want to live in Hawaii.
Fuck yeah. Stay right here.
And then just the breeding.
Yeah,
and then there's also the
entertainment business.
All the pretty people from Cincinnati,
they got on a bus and
they came out here yet.
I'm going to make it look at these
cheeks. Yeah, I'm going to make it.
How many of them make it
very, very, very, very, very few.
It's almost not even worth it. Almost
not even worth it. Unless you make it.
Then you're like, oh,
I love Jamie Bitch Dat,
Dat da who won. Yeah, that's right.
Fist full of cash and throwing them
up in the air. Make an Instagram.
Video's rolling around in your silk
sheets filled with hundred dollar bills.
I almost feel like it's best seen,
like in the age we live in now,
it's better to just stay where you're at
and put shit out online. Oh, online. Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
But I think people are still caught
up in the mystique of like coming to
Hollywood, making it in Hollywood. The
even people that do big things online,
they still want to do like legitimate
things. Like I'd love to do movies.
You know who love to do TV.
They want to do things that pay them less
money than they do piano. Youtube Star.
Yeah. Really? Huh? Youtube
pays a lot of money now.
Like if you're a big like Logan
Paul type dude. Yeah. They make,
he makes a shit load of money on youtube.
Like who fucking pays in my who?
Who signs his check advertisements.
So selling advocates,
these videos on the videos get millions
and millions of hits and he gets
millions of dollars from
advertisement revenue.
Probably more money than most
successful Sitcom people. Yeah.
If you think of like someone who's on a
successful television show, you think,
well that guy has gotta be palling.
I Bet Logan Paul makes twice as much
money as those people. Fuck, I know.
Crazy. And in this people like Pooty
pie. How much does that guy make?
He's got like 77 million subscribers.
So the,
but the only thing about that guy is he
likes to say controversial shit and he
gets in trouble and then sometimes they
pull ads off of him and stuff like that.
But I think if you're one of
those like Ninjas, he another one,
that video game guy, those people
make outrageous sums of money.
Outrageous sums of money. Like playing
video games and talking shit. Yeah,
I sought,
it was like this little kid.
It was like a seven year old may
like $20 million doing toys. Yeah.
Ryan. Oh, Ryan's toy review.
That's the kid at him.
He made 22 million in
2018 by reviewing toys.
This little Asian kid ran
a little kid right there.
How much do you think the
parents let them keep?
I'd tell my parents or suck my dick
fuck out of my room. You clean my room,
set up that fucking video
and you cleaned my room.
This muffling just wiffle ball Paul.
21 million.
So he looked at that 21
million just by talking to,
he had a Disney show for awhile.
He was on a Disney show that my kids
watch and then he decided, fuck that.
I'd rather just be in my house.
What does it say on his wall team
team Paul 10 that's the team 10 squad.
He'd be like painted down on his wall.
He's got a mansion.
It's to all fucked up inside.
They've got one of those
Lego installations too that
some guy came in and put it
like it was all and as wall.
Oh, interesting. So who's
number three? Let's see. Ah,
this is a group of guys,
dude, dude, perfect.
They make a like five man sports
crew. Oh, I've seen those guys.
They do stuff with bows and Arrow,
all kinds of things.
They've been doing it for a few years.
They kind of like,
they've been burning down like any
kind of chip shot you can think of.
So they made $20 million or five of them,
so 5 million bucks each.
It's not nothing to sneeze at.
And then what else guys?
This solo like Dan TDM and he made 18
million Holla slash ball and I can go
anywhere. Oh, Jeffrey Star.
Is that a guy or girl?
Jeff makeup star makeup artists.
Since the era has reinvented himself
as a beauty mogul, wait a minute.
You say himself a you mis-gendering him.
I didn't say that article.
Mis-Gendered I think
that's a whatever that is.
What is this one mark up video plier
17 nobody ever see that guy before.
That guy could go anywhere.
Meanwhile, I made $17 million.
Vanos gaming,
Canadian Gamer,
Evan Fong plays mainstream titles
like the call of duty plays games.
17 million. It's man,
another one 16 million.
We'll leave this guy hanging
out. Pooty Pie. Dan [inaudible],
who is his Pooty pie?
Like you mentioned him before.
I never heard another guy that just,
he's a famous guy. I don't
know too much about it. Dumb.
I never watched him the most.
Followed 72.5 million followers.
I think the reason why he makes less
money is because of the advertisers have
abandoned him cause he dropped
some bombs. Oh, he did? Yeah.
What does it say up there? What does it
say about his, uh, no below him. Below.
They're Swedish gamer. The most
followed. Yeah, a backlash last year.
Rat ranch of antisemetic videos.
That's right. Antisemetic he said he,
he,
but it was like he was joking around and
he like was making fun of antisemetic
people. But while I was wearing a Hitler
outfit, right? Something like that.
And they were like, yeah, it's kind
of tastes, but again, too much work.
Like you paid some people like
Mitt to makeup, Fiverr video,
putting up signs that they
didn't know what they just
did. It does that too. Yeah.
Well Anyway, point being, you're right,
they can make a shit load of money
just being on youtube and on twitch,
playing video games.
I know that's real.
That's like if you're a CEO of
a gigantic fucking corporation,
you work 15 hours a day, you be super
happy to make with these assholes
with the exception that a little kid,
I'm going to give a pass.
But the rest of them do. They're just
assholes on youtube making money.
I think you have to be an
asshole to get attention to.
I mean that's like part of the thing
you got to be. What does Miranda sings?
Is She in that list?
Just the top 10?
She's not in the top 10 but I mean there's
probably like a hundred people that
make 7 million. Oh I
know Mami. Just get me.
So I got my online project coming out.
Train Bjj,
online.com. Yeah. Nice. Um, shit to shit.
And you're training Bjj online.com.
Is that just like from
white belt to black belt?
Like you learn no curriculum?
No,
not even like that cause I'm really care
about belts. Okay. To be honest with you,
I care about being effective and you know,
as much as I do like Jujitsu for MMA
is different for like competition.
Sure. Very different. Yeah. So like
that's what I'm focusing on. You know,
the differences and to make this shit
work again because I think a lot of
people are doing Jujitsu
wrong for MMA you to use it.
I thinking they're using it
wrong. How so? Um, you know like,
cause when you talk about like Jujitsu
the way it's been played recently,
it's like well [inaudible] just to
plate and competition all about getting
points, passing card, getting a back, put
the hooks in, that shit don't work in him.
May Hey their planet
for points. Right. So,
um,
I do it.
I've just created and developed a bunch
of positions to we fuck people up,
we hurt people and then submit them.
That's the key.
You should Jujitsu to hurt
people then submit them.
When you say you use it to hurt people,
you mean use it to maintain a position
and land strikes, punching people,
punching people and then submit them
and soften them up a little bit. Yeah.
So like the mentality of it is
different. You know, I'm not, I'm not,
cause I think about it,
you're like,
if I were when you were
doing Jujitsu right now,
like in order for me to pass your guard
it would take me fucking 10 minutes.
You know you have five
minutes to do this shit.
I'm not trying to pass your guard.
I'm trying to punch you. Yeah.
And also the other thing about it is
like there's certain positions where you
really just can't get away with if
someone's punching. Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
Like especially the bottom bottom game
has suffered tremendously because it
hasn't evolved.
Like Jujitsu has an evolved from the
bottom and like that's something that,
like I said, when I stopped competing, I
studied, studied, studied, say what works,
what doesn't work and now I figured
out like all these different systems.
I think that Jujitsu has evolved
from the bottom in, in high level.
Jujitsu competitions. We just haven't
seen as much of it in MMA. Oh.
For competition. Like Jujitsu
is as great as it's ever been.
It's beautiful to watch. Like the
way these guys move, you know,
watching Keena Cornelius like slither
on a floor. It's fucking beautiful,
but I would do okay in a mean way,
but like most like just
theoretically most guys wouldn't.
I think Gary tone and it's going to do
very well. He's doing well already. Yeah,
I think so.
Tony in one FC.
But I think Gary Tonin has
such a high level ground game,
particularly with his leg locks. Yeah.
And you know, and he could do everything.
Your back arm bar, you, whatever
you, whatever you need. And he's um,
he's making his way through the ranks at
war. I'm very excited about one. Yeah,
me too. I like one FC, I'm a big fan,
Lido gay tone and like he, he came,
I don't know if he wrestled before,
but he has like a,
a wrestler's mentality
when it comes to Jujitsu.
Like he's very aggressive and he's
like, he's Fairless, you know,
he's fucking on the money. So I like
his chances against anybody. Yeah.
I liked his chances to be a
world champion. Yeah. Me Too.
In MMA in any organization.
And, but I think on the ground,
like he's so far above almost everybody
else he's going to face. I know,
you know, especially when it
comes to the leg lock came,
his leg locks are just that whole Donna,
her death squad, you know, there's,
they're raising some fucking killers over
and I'm studying as shit now because I
think there's a place for it. And
I think that in MMA people, aw,
that shit don't work. They just
don't get punched in the face. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. I'm like,
cause MMA guys don't really know how to
do it. Right. Right.
To not doing it right.
They're just swinging her
leg around trying to squeeze,
they're not doing it right. Right.
Well, even Paul, Horace, you know, um,
when they were, um, when they were
talking about Gary Tonin was gonna face,
Paul Horace Porras is so much bigger
and so much stronger than Gary,
Tony and Gary Tona and still
threaten the fuck out of them.
Hadn't been some real bad spots. And you
know, they went to a drop of the draw.
Like if it were pointing to, I mean,
if you were to see who won wanes. Yeah.
First of all, they're not
the same side. Right. I mean,
what does Gary fighting in one fc one
50, 55 probably. Yeah. 200. 200 pounds.
He said go rilla. Yeah, he needs,
he's on every Mexican supplement.
Have an event like the
little pit bull on yeah,
no wicki would come to him with it,
but like a fucking paper towel and just
wipe his [inaudible] got everything on
this towel. Every fucking, every
metabolite that's every existed.
Yeah. He's a Jew. He's a
gigantic guy. And, but they
were saying that his leg game,
even though it's effective in terms of
MMA, like his transitions in his entries,
they're very limited and they're obvious
and they were seeing them comment and
then he showed it and then they
competed against him. Yeah.
But I like Gary Tone and I think he's
going to do wonderful over there. I mean,
it'll be interesting to see him fight.
Uh,
I mean obviously Eddie Alvarez, that'll
be there probably in the same division.
So like it would be interesting to
see that. Yes. Very, very interesting.
Very interesting. Yeah. Eddie
Alvarez going over there. It's huge.
I'm mighty mouse going over there is huge.
You know,
Brandon verus the heavyweight champion.
Now you know Brenda Barrett's
fucking people up over this. Yes.
Yes.
Under the radar.
Because then you don't really hear much
about him being over there fighting.
And it seems like someone he knows
been south of the border as well,
about 240 pounds. Oh my God. He's so
jacked. He never seen Brandon Vera.
Now I haven't seen him in years.
Dude.
I didn't even really was fighting
over this. Some mash and people. Yeah.
Smashing people.
And he's like 240 plus pounds now.
No shit to giant neck fucking traps.
Jacked his fuck.
Is he still training at alliance down?
I believe so. I believe so, yeah.
But I'll tell you what man, like
you were saying, that leg lock game,
like Ryan Hall has the ability to beat
anybody in the featherweight division.
Yeah. If he catches a whole of a limb.
Yeah. Yeah. I think he could beat,
I think he'd beat Holloway the
same as he'd beat anybody else.
And I'm not saying he can beat them,
but I'm just saying like if he gets
all done, he's, yeah, he's, yeah,
he could tap anybody that's, yeah. His
level of Jujitsu, his understanding,
his technique, his skill
levels. Very, very, very high.
Like World Championship
caliber, Huh? Yeah. Yeah.
But there's a bunch of garlic there.
That's Brandon vera now jacked.
He's jacked dude. Show me.
Show me. Yeah, look at that.
Like when he was in the UFC,
he was skinny and slim. Well,
he's finding two oh five and heavyweight
in the UFC. Now he's just heavyweight.
And so he just packed on some
meat, put up, put a video of like,
there's a Brandon vera
highlight Kao video out there.
But uh, he's people up over
there, man. Let's see something.
Just a, that one that's on
the other ago. The truth,
Brandon Vera highlights. Don't,
don't, don't, don't, don't, don't,
don't Mr Freak z's 75,
whatever the fuck that is.
Whoever the gentleman is to put together
this highlight reel. It says the truth.
Brandon Vera highlights February one
championships, highlight contest.
Let me see some fighting parts.
Is it all now? Here we go.
Boom.
And Brandon Vera always had like
very high level striking. Yeah,
he was always Chris.
Yeah.
And they see the one fc you can head kick
and he kicked people apparently in the
back of the head, which is kind,
Kinda fucked up. Um, I don't know, uh,
what the competition is alike in
the heavyweight division at one FC,
like what level is,
but I imagine with the size of the
organization about how big it is that the
competition is going to continue to
rise and all weight classes right now.
Like in terms of the number
of people that are watching,
it rivals the UFC does it really? It's
John and in Asia. Judge a judge, a judge,
a giant. But I think it's going to
continue. They're making a lot of money,
throwing a lot of money,
yet elite fighters.
I'm hoping they brings him more because
they don't really have a strong American
presence. Well, I think they're signaling
by having Eddie Alvarez come over there.
Misha Tate is running shit over there
now too, as well as a rich Franklin.
He's running things.
I think he's the vice president there now.
A lot of shit happening over there.
We need it. Then we had another pride.
We need something like that. Yeah,
we do. Yeah, we do. I listen.
I'm all for it because I hate,
you know,
I work with a lot of guys and I hate when
he fucking don't have nowhere to work.
Exactly. You know, and
like if they're just,
if we only rely on the UFC
and we all know how that is,
the one bad performance means you're out.
So it's, or a bad judging, right? Yeah.
Yeah. What did you think about the PFL?
I love the PFL. Yeah. Yeah. I love it.
I love the structure.
What's his name?
Sean O'connell says something
very interesting just off the top,
but he said I just made $1 million and
all I had to do was win and he repeated
it. All I had to do was
win. So to me I was like,
I guess he was just saying like he
didn't have to be a character and this is
coming from prior to the only character
in Pfl. And he said that because like,
oh no, no, no, no, my mother guys can
fucking do that shit, you know. But, um,
but who's watching? I don't think
anybody was, that's the thing.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
I'm surprised he'd be Vinny [inaudible]
when the whole time I thought so too.
But um, but then when I
thought about it, I said, damn,
he's been training with Jeremy Horn,
his probably his whole career and Jeremy
Horn is a wizard to yeah. So yeah.
But um, but I trained a couple of
the Russians for four to Pfl um,
bag of man. He won the welterweight
against Ray Cooper to third. Yeah.
Ray Cooper's they'll fucking beast.
I know. Five, seven. I know. 170 lbs.
Throwing bricks. I know the, when
he fought Jake and beat him twice,
like that stopped him twice a week. Jesus
state championship wrestler. I know. Uh,
yeah, I was, you know, I
didn't think he was, um,
cause my guy took them down early and I
was kind of surprised he took them down
as early as he did because he
has a state champ. But what? Um,
he seems small for the division.
Yeah.
He could probably fight at one 55 just
going to have a little more success. Yeah.
But I like the fact that at
least these guys have an option.
It's a place they can win a million,
million dollars. Then the finals,
like leading up to it, they're
still making good money. Yeah.
Like the loser made 250 and then like
how did they get eyeballs though?
I don't know. That's the problem.
That is the problem. Right?
That's the problem with everything.
I mean even with Bella tour,
I mean the way they got eyeballs
was to have like boys crazy fight.
I mean that's the way they get eyeballs
to have. They have to have someone,
they have to have someone
who's got a name, you know?
I mean that's the reason why they
brought over Tito and jail and all these,
you know, it's hard. And that's what
I was saying like Sean O'Connor,
like if you ever hear him talk like he's
very charismatic and charming and he's
the only person who probably can handle
himself on a mic. It's any radio guy?
I think so. Yeah. I think he's got a
radio. I think he's a sports radio guy.
And for him to say all I had to do was
win. Implying that he didn't have to talk.
Like what does that say for, you know,
the Times Schulte who won the lightweight,
who can't speak, you know? I don't know.
I can't imagine where they go in three
years because they're not going to have
many stars. Well, it seems
like, what does it say?
2018 one championship registered and
average of 11 million viewers per live
event across its core markets.
According to Nielsen.
That's a lot of fucking people.
2015 his figure was less than one
oh pop up ads got us son of a bitch.
2015 this figure was less than 1
million viewers per live events.
So in three years they went from less
than 1 million viewers per live event to
11 million viewers per live event.
That's fucking amazing.
Of course,
across its core markets.
The article was comparing it
to Mba viewership in Asia.
Dramatic increase in TV viewership.
Fantastic.
Can't be more happy. Hope they
keep growing. I hope they,
I hope they develop like real legit
stars and also they have legit world
championships across every
combat sport over there.
They've got yachts and Caroline is doing,
he's doing all the time. I saw that.
Yeah. Nicky hold skin is doing kickboxing
over there. I saw that. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
They're,
I mean they're,
they're bringing in world beaters
and bay basically every discipline.
Yeah. I mean, I love it. I mean,
you know, we, we both have a field,
our affiliation with the UFC,
but like without the other organizations,
the game don't last. Exactly. The game
can't last. Exactly. It's so critical.
It's so critical that
there's more opportunities.
And then also it raises the
level of the UFC as well.
Raises everybody rising tide raises
all boats. Yeah. Really does.
Hopefully EOC kind of take a page
from what I've seen does the weight
thing. I would love it. They sports,
I'm into that.
But yeah.
Were trying to figure out what to
do about weight cutting. I mean,
they really are. They're trying
to figure it out. And, um,
I brought to their attention the
one fc plan, how the one fc does it.
They basically eliminated, everybody
goes up await, you know, they,
they moved every champion up a weight
class. They do hydration chests.
They find out what your actual weight is
and they don't let you fuck around and
you fight it. What you really way, I
mean that's really what it should do.
And if you need to be
in a lighter way class,
guess what fat boy tell him to
fucking get on a bike. But listen man,
do it again next year to try
and get next year. I love that.
Like the beginning of the year.
This is what you're going away and
fight it for a year. Stay here. Yeah.
If you don't like it next year fucking
get another weight class. That's right.
All right dude. We stayed
three hours. Damn crazy.
Time flies by the time you see how that
is. We finally did it. We finally did.
I'm standing,
we are here for like 30 minutes,
15 minutes and let's do it
again man. Yeah man. Listen.
Give everybody your social media
dresses at Dean Thomas at the I n t I,
N Thomas, or you go to me at a,
yeah. Or at Trane Bjj. Online.
Okay. Yeah, so Dean Thomas
on Instagram, Twitter,
Facebook, all, everything.
All right. Beautiful. Thank
you very much. Pleasure, man.
It was fun. That was fun. All right
folks. We'll see you soon. Bye.
Yeah.